Three,
two,
one.
And we're alive.
How are you sir?
Hey,
I'm great.
Thanks for being here,
man.
I really appreciate it.
It is the coolest thing I've done really
well,
you know,
remember that far back.
That's pretty cool.
Um,
I watched your ted talk on what was the
word that you used?
A Leicester Land and uh,
it felt hopeless,
like if people don't know what I'm
talking about because you just give like
a brief synopsis of the way you were
describing how completely completely
rigged our election system is and what
it actually takes to be elected and how
much of the time they spend is involved
in raising money and why.
Yeah.
So we've got a system where we have a
money primary and then we have a regular
election and in the money primary to
compete,
you gotta raise tons of money to be able
to fund your campaign.
And when you raise that money you raise
it from a tiny,
tiny fraction of the one percent.
So unless in the Ted talk about lesser
known and I said,
you know,
imagine a place called Lester land where
basically it's the lesters who rule.
And by the lesters I mean the same
proportion of people named Lester as in
the United States right now.
So there's about 150,000
Americans named Lester.
I'm one of them.
But here we are,
the Leicester.
So imagine a world ruled by Lester land,
um,
because that's essentially the world we
have because of the way we fund our
campaigns because there's about 150,000
men who give even just the maximum
contribution to one political candidate.
And if you ask who the number of people
who give the maximum contribution over
the course of a campaign,
meaning in the primary and the general
election,
it's about 22,000
Americans in 2014 who gave them maximum
contribution to one political campaigns.
So what that means is it's a tiny,
tiny fraction who are the most important
funders of political campaigns and
candidates for Congress.
Members of Congress spend 30 to 70
percent of their time sucking up to this
tiny,
tiny fraction.
And so is it any surprise that you see
congress bending over backwards to keep
those guys happy?
Because they know without those people,
they don't have a shot at getting back
into congress.
And the way you were describing it as
when you were saying it as lester land,
it was like,
imagine if we were this screwed up.
That was essentially what you're saying.
Yeah.
But we're more screwed up lester land.
Yeah,
we're more.
That was a disturbing video because I
was realized there was emerging as you
were speaking.
I was like,
wait a minute,
is it that bad?
Yeah.
You know,
it's,
I actually,
since that video have come to think it's
even worse.
So like clearance land.
Well,
it could be worse because it's even
smaller number.
And if you look at the number of Super
Pac donors,
you know,
the really critical super packed hundred
about a hundred people who gave more
than half of the Super Pac money in the
last presidential election.
100,
you know,
so this is a really tiny,
tiny number.
Um,
but what this tiny number represents and
the way we fund campaigns is the
extraordinary inequality on that
dimension,
right?
But since,
since I was focused on the money,
I've more recently started thinking
about the other screwed up dimension.
So think about gerrymandering.
You know,
we gerrymander districts in America,
so that about 85 percent of the house
seats in the United States Congress are
safe seats,
which means if you're a republican in a
safe seat,
democratic district,
your views just never mattered to the
Congressperson,
cause that vote of a Republican will
never determine who's in Congress or a
Democrat and Republican district.
That's the same.
Okay,
but that doesn't mean those congress
people are not afraid about reelection.
Of course,
they are afraid about whether there'll
be reluctant,
but they're afraid not of a Democrat
running against a Republican,
they afraid of an even more extreme
republican running against the incumbent
Republican.
So what those incumbents in those safe
seat districts do is they obsess about
what the extremists in their own party
cares about.
So the extremists on the left and the
right have this ability to leverage
extraordinary influence inside of the
House of Representatives simply because
we've decided to gerrymander these
districts to create these safe seats.
So those extremists are a kind of
lester's too.
There are more of them,
a more democratic than lester land,
but they too have enormous influence
over ordinary people in most ordinary
people's views.
Then to these congress people just don't
matter.
That feels hopeless for a dummy like me
sit on the outside looking at this,
I'm like,
God,
if this is this deeply entrenched with.
I mean I guess it's not technically
corruption because it's all legal,
but it's an entanglement with money and
with influence that.
I mean,
how do you unwind this?
Yeah.
So that point is really critical.
It's not technically illegal and what
that means is that people are engaged in
this or not doing wrong things.
They're just playing by the rules,
their plan with the system.
It's just that the system has become
corrupted.
When did it start?
Well,
I think that the moment the United
States Congress begins to fall apart in
a really dramatic and interesting way is
when Newt Gingrich becomes speaker of
the house.
So when the Republicans take control of
Congress in [inaudible] 95,
so the first time
the Republicans have taken control of
the House of Representatives in 40
years.
So the house becomes incredibly
competitive.
Each election,
you know,
is up for grabs.
Who's going to control the house?
So Gingrich turns his members in the
House into perpetual fundraisers.
It's basically we got raise the money to
defend ourselves next time around.
And then the Democrats followed suit.
So the Democrats turned their members
into perpetual fundraisers and they
changed the rules about like,
who gets to be chairman of committees?
It's no longer like who's the person
with the most experience,
with the most insight increasingly
becomes who raises the most money and
the Democratic Party.
I know about the Democratic Party.
The Republicans don't talk to me much,
but the Democratic Party increasingly
changes its focus from what are the
policies that our members care about
too.
What are we going to do to make sure
that you as a member meet your
fundraising target?
And so from 95 until today,
the institution becomes an institution
focused on the game of getting
reelected.
I'm Jim Cooper,
a Democrat from Tennessee who went to
Congress first in 1983.
So He's been there for a long time.
Um,
Cooper says Capitol Hill has become a
kind of farm league forK street.
Okay.
So what he means by that is members go
there,
they learn how to raise money,
they become focused obsessively on
raising money.
But one of the things that they're
really focused on,
it's how do they go from Capitol Hill to
becoming a lobbyist because that's where
the real money is.
A member of Congress gets paid about as
much as the students.
I educate at the Harvard law school in
their first year as Lawyers Co.
So to ordinary americans,
there's a lot of money,
but two people on capitol hill,
it doesn't seem like a lot of money,
but then they go and become a lobbyist.
They can make 10 timeS that as a
lobbyist.
And so what cooper says is you have this
institution which has become so focused
on the money that it's just a
institution for producing influence that
can be sold.
And first the congressmen are basically
sucking up to the people who wAnt to buy
influence and then the congressman
become the people buying influence
themselves because they're working as
lobbyists for these important interests.
So they're in the rigged game.
They understand how it gets rigged and
they work to rig it.
Yeah.
They see,
they see this as their,
their business plan.
It's their honeypot.
Yeah.
And there is,
um,
whatever the district is outside of
Washington dc and Virginia,
where there's some ungodly number of
wealthy people per capita where there's
more,
there's more lobbyists in that area than
anywhere else in the United States.
And that's this giant collection of
wealth,
right?
Washington dc is an incredibly
prosperous place.
And anybody who's been there,
um,
you know,
for a long who've seen it for a long
time,
like I,
I clerked there in the early 19 nineties
and it was pretty grungy place,
but it's a really opulent city now.
It's like the golden city on the hill,
you know the ahs and the reason for that
is the amount of money that's been
poured into that district for the
purpose of buying influence to buy
legislation that makes it so these
inCumbent dinosaur corporations that
have protected themselves against
competition across tHe country can,
can,
can continue to profit.
It's a weird place though because even
though it's incredibly wealthy,
it's also incredibly poor.
There's a vast different extra.
The spectrum is really wide because,
I mean that was when in the nineties was
that.
That's the marion barry time,
right?
Yeah.
so that was when,
I mean he won as mayor again when he
came back after being arrested for
smoking crack and people are like,
whatever little crack.
Yeah.
It was an ugly place.
That and it's becoming,
you know,
grotesque place now from the,
from the standpoint of the principles of
what america's supposed to be.
yeah.
Because the privilege.
There are not people who are privileged
because they've elon musk like and
rented a great new product or they've
worked incredibly hard and competitive
marketplace and succeeded.
They're privileged because they've
leveraged influence in a corrupt system
to to profit and the people who are
failing their,
you know,
a lot of reasons they're failing is just
we don't have a competitive,
powerful economy that gives them the
opportunities right now because that,
that district,
Washington dc,
because it's got no effective
representation is one of the worst
represented districts in the country.
So essentially this all started out with
new green gingrich's group and they
decided to spend so much time
concentrating on fundraising and then
once that became successful,
everyone else followed suit.
Yeah.
So the game became no longer how do we
legislate for America,
but how do we rally our troops to raise
the money we need to win in the next
election?
The game is just about the election.
I mean,
you know,
my,
my mother lives in hilton head,
which is of course a very republican
district,
but they elected their first democrat,
Joe Cunningham and joe.
My moTher loved him and wanted to
support him.
My mother is a republican,
but here he was.
She wanted to support a democrat.
So I sent a check for on her behalf to
this democrat,
the day he was elected,
he started raising money for the next
election,
his whole focus from that moment on and
now we started a big membership
organization or are they going to get
members to sort of help him sort of get
back to congress the next time around.
Their sole focus is the elections.
And this is really different in the 19
eighties,
you know,
they would go to Washington for 18
months,
they would do the work of governing and
then for six months they do the work of
politicking.
Um,
so,
you know,
to a year and a half they could figure
out how to solve the problems of
America.
And then for half a year they figured
out how to get reelected.
That's no longer the game.
The game now is from day one.
How do we raise the funds?
We need to make sure we can get
reelected.
Um,
and with the democrats extraordinary
turnaround in this last election,
you be damn sure.
That's
exactly the obsessive focus that we'll
be going into 20 slash 20.
And if there's no other viable
alternative,
this is a game that they have to play,
good people have to play at this point.
It's not like you can have the good
people who say,
I'm not going to play this game.
I mean there are some famous people who
Can say,
I'm not going to play this game.
Know alexandria,
occasional cortez.
I mean she doesn't have to raise money,
I'm sure,
and people on the right to you know,
who are the famous people in,
right?
They don't have to worry about this,
but the ordinary congress person knows,
given the way the system is right now,
they've got an obsessive focus on how to
raise money in what they know that that
means is they develop a sixth sense,
a constant awareness about how what they
do will affect their ability to raise
money,
becoming the words of the x files,
shape shifters,
as they constantly adjust their views in
light of what they know will help them
to raise money.
There was a congressman leslie burned
democrat from Virginia who describes
that when she went to congress,
she was told by a colleague,
quote always leaned to the green than to
clarify.
She went on,
you know,
he was not an environmentalist.
So the point is like,
you know,
in your heart of hearts which way you
got to go to make sure,
and if you're good and you're smart,
you'd never say anything to indicate it,
but it's operating,
but sometimes you're not so smart.
So in the tax bill,
the leading up to the passage of the
last tax cut,
the one point $6,000,000,000,000
gift to corporations and wealthy people,
primarily a congressman,
New York stood on the floor of the house
and said,
you know,
my donors have told me that if we don't
deliver on this,
I should never call him again.
I should never call them again.
So it's basically as simple and clear as
possible.
You don't reduce our taxes.
Don't ever ask us for more money.
And that's the reality of what
Washington has become.
Now once this gets started and it moves
in this direction that we don't have a
long history of this to understand the,
the waves and the ins and the outs of
the tide,
it just,
this is just what it is and it keeps
moving in the same general direction.
How would that,
that ever stop?
How would there ever be some sort of
reform that puts this back into a
position where it makes sense and it's
tenable?
Yeah.
So you know,
I've been in this business for about 12
years now in the business of like trying
to figure out what can we do to reform
this corrupted system and you know,
part of me feels as you said,
like it's hopeless,
but part of me feels like it's the most
hopeful moments we've seen because like
a decade ago when I would go around and
say,
you know,
we got this really corrupted system and
like money is people saying no,
when you talk about we just have to
focus on getting the people we want
elected.
And if we get the people we want to like
it,
we'll get the policies.
We're past now,
almost everybody realizes that until we
fix this broken congress,
nothing else can happen.
So it's not like this is the most
important
issue out there.
You know,
you could think climate change or
healthcare or jobs or comp competitive
mode,
you could think those are the important
issues.
But what people are increasingly seeing
is that this is the first issue.
If we don't fix this,
we don't fix anything.
And what's really encouraging to me is
that that frame is increasingly being
embraced by important leaders.
So,
you know,
about six years ago,
I think nancy pelosi was on jon
stewart's show,
the daily show,
and stuart said,
you know,
the whole system is corrupt.
And nancy pelosi's no,
no,
the system's not corrupt.
People in the system are corrupt,
but the system is not corrupt.
And jon stewart just had a field day
because of how ridiculous that statement
is now.
But now nancy polosi is gonna introduce
this hr one,
the most ambitious and comprehensive
reform package that Washington I think
has ever seen.
I mean,
it is unbelievable in its breadth.
Um,
so it has public funding of
congressional campaigns.
So that congressmen don't spend 30 to 70
percent of their time sucking up to the
lesters.
It has a mandate to end gerrymandering,
political partisan gerrymandering,
exercising congress's power under the
constitution to tell the states,
clean this mess up.
It has an incredible,
um,
ethics package to kind of close,
block the revolving door.
So congressmen are not running off the k
street and it has an incredible
restoration of voting rights.
The rest voter,
a restoration of voting rights act,
automatic voter registration.
It's the most comprehensive package of
political reform,
I think the civil rights bill of the
generation.
But of course nobody outside of
Washington has heard anything about it
because most people look at what
Washington does and says it's just a
game the democrats are playing to
embarrass the republicans.
How will they stop congressmen from
becoming lobbyists?
Well,
one thing,
they do a and then build loopholes into
it,
but one thing they can do is they can
basically say,
um,
once your congressman,
you can't be a lobbyist for five years
and five years or whatever the time is.
But the more fundamental factors,
you know,
if you change the way you fund
campaigns,
if it was no longer the lobbyists who
are kind of channeling the money in or
that we're getting their clients to
channel the money and then it's not like
there wouldn't be lobbyists anymore,
they just wouldn't be so well paid.
They wouldn't be as valuable.
And if they're not as valuable,
it's not as valuable for them to pay the
congressmen and incredible amount of
money to become a lobbyist.
You know,
they would become almost like lawyers
policy wonks that kind of go to capitol
hill and say,
here's what will happen if you adopt
this legislation,
you know,
that's an important part of the process.
but they wouldn't be the mockers in the
system.
They wouldn't be the people who called
the shots.
And so the value of their services would
fall.
And if the value of their services fell,
then it wouldn't so much sense to go and
become a lobbyist.
Maybe you'd come home and be a doctor
again or come home and like be a
businessperson again or do whatever you
want back in your district.
So I think if you change the way you
fund campaigns,
you would change 70 percent of the
problem,
you would just fix it right then.
And these other things are good
additions,
but not as critical.
But without changing the way you fund
campaigns.
I think all of these other changes are
relevant.
I just can't get over the money.
You always hear the phrase take money
out of politics.
It's a constant phrase,
but that's not really possible now.
And I don't think it's really good point
isn't the point isn't to get money out.
The point is to get money that doesn't
represent a tiny fraction of the special
interests controlling how congress
people think.
So I think today a congressman from
California rogue kahana is going to
introduce a bill that he hopes will be
eventually part of whatever this big
reform packages that would create a way
of funding campaigns where everybody
gets a voucher or a set of vouchers.
you know,
seattle has done this for city elections
where everybody gets for $25 vouchers
that are only usable to fund campaigns.
So a candidate comes around and tries to
persuade you to give him or her the
voucher and then they take that voucher
and they use it to fund campaigns.
Okay.
If roca han is bill passed and everybody
had vouchers to use to fund
congressional campaigns and you know,
the idea is basically you take the
rebate of the first $50 of your taxes,
which every american pays at least $50
to the federal government.
You take that first $50,
you give it back and you give it in the
form of a voucher and you say,
take this voucher and help fund
campaigns with it.
Congressmen would still be raising
money.
They'd still be spending a lot of time
raising money,
but they wouldn't be raising money from
the tiny fraction of the one percent.
They'd be raising money from everybody.
And so the point is that you would be
using that money to spread the influence
in the way that democracy is supposed to
spread the influence to every american
as opposed to the influence in a tiny,
tiny fraction of the one percent.
So that wouldn't get less money.
I think that could be more money in the
system,
but it wouldn't be corrupting money
because it would be money that is
democratically accountable,
but the lesters of the world would
probably try to put the kibosh on that
before it ever got movement.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
the biggest block to anything like hr,
one happening is that the most
influential people in Washington have
the most to lose,
right?
The lobbyists,
you know,
the value of the industry of lobbying
just collapses and those people are
going to fight like hell to block it.
Which is why as wonderful as it is to me
to see somebody like nancy polosi take
up the charge and say,
here it is.
Here's a package of reform and it's
going to be the first thing we do.
Fix democracy first.
What?
What's true?
What's obvious about this is without a
president taking up the charge,
it's never gonna happen,
and what's most depressing to
is that right now in the democratic
party,
you don't have any candidate for
president who's making reform a even an
important issue,
let alone a primary issue.
And of courSe we had a president who is
elected under the drain,
the swamp slogan,
but of course nobody believes he has an
implant or have any intent to do
anything to drain that swamp.
Yeah.
I'm hoping that having him in office is
such a that the whole thing was such a
cluster fuck and that so many people are
so disturbed that it's going to make
people more politically active and more
aware of the consequences of having
someone like that in office.
Yeah.
And actually weirdly unifying because
even though the democrats are not doing
this right now,
which is really depressing to me,
you know,
we,
we have these things that we know we
disagree about and we like fueled the
politics of hate as we kind of yell at
each other about these things.
BuT there's a set of issues that we all
agree about and the,
and the most important set of issues we
all agree about is the deeply corrupted
nature of this government.
And there was a poll done by university
of Maryland,
the middle of 2016,
asking about anger and frustration with
government found the highest level of
frustration in the history of polling.
And then when they asked the reasons why
they were so angry and so disaffected
with their government,
the reasons people gave were all the
same things like the influence of money,
the influence of lobbyists,
the parties care more about corporations
and about.
And then then we broke them down about
how to republicans think about this and
how the democrats think about this.
There was no statistical difference
between republicans and democrats.
you know,
sometimes the democrats were more
concerned.
Sometimes the republicans and the
levels,
we're at like 80 and 90 percent.
So literally 84 percent of americans
would say it is big money that is
corrupting the way our congress
functions.
Right?
So here is common ground.
And what was so extraordinarY about the
2016 election is watched a republican
candidates stand on a debate stage.
In september of twentY 15,
Donald Trump stood on a debate stage and
pointed to every one of those kennedy's
and said,
I own all of you.
I've given all of you money and I know
The way the system works and the system
is corrupt and he called super pacs and
abomination and he attacked the idea of
money in politics and so what that
signaled is that republicans to could be
rallied to this cause of addressing this
deeply corrupted political system.
If only we could find the candidates who
would do it,
and I think what Donald Trump has done
is teed up this moment where we can step
back and say,
look,
we disagree about a lot of things,
whether it's gmo or climate change,
whether it's healthcare for all or
college for all,
whatever.
We disagree about a loving.
We got to work a lot of things out.
But here is something we all agree about
and we should be smart enough to realize
if we don't fix this,
the none of the things we're arguing
about matter.
You know,
you can't.
It's not serious to stand on a debate
stage and say you you support single
payer healthcare
without also saying,
but first we're going to fix this
corrupted system because there's no way
to get single payer healthcare in a
world where doctors and pharmaceutical
companies and insurance companies are
funding elections.
You can't say you're goIng to get
climate change legislation in America
without addressing the corrupting
influence of money in politics because
the oil camp that the dirty energy
industry has an enormous opportunity to
block this,
changed through the way we fund
campaign.
So this is a moment where we should be
able to get everybody in this political
system to step back and say,
hey,
wait.
The system is broken.
We can see as broken.
The first thing we have to do is to fix
the broken congress,
and if we fix that congress,
then we have a chance to have an
argument about what policy makes sense
for America.
And we each have our views,
but no views are different.
But the thing we don't agree about,
we should be able to agree on.
Now,
if that's a universal agreement amongst
republicans and democrats,
that funding and that money and that
all,
all of this is what's ruining politics.
The people that are donating all this
moneY,
the,
these,
the lesters of the world,
what could they possibly do to stop this
reform and what's their reaction to this
kind of reform?
Yeah.
YeAh.
So let me be clear about one really
important thing.
I,
when I say republicans and democrats,
what I mean as people in the districts
across America,
I don't mean in Washington like mitch
mcconnell is,
I think the focus of evil in the modern
world.
Mitch mcconnell will block any reform
here at all.
So,
you know,
nancy polozi can offer what she wants,
but it'll never get through the senate
because mitch mcconnell and so there are
many republicans in Washington.
We're going to block any reform.
But,
um,
but when you ask,
you know,
the republicans in Washington and the
lesters,
what can they do to stop it?
Well,
the game,
the game strategy's clear,
they've deployed it before,
right?
So,
um,
you know,
they'll,
they'll say things like,
this is welfare for politicians.
Um,
this is just corrupting free speech.
You don't believe in the first amendment
if you don't believe that the koch
brothers or the soros is,
have the right to spend unlimited
amounts of money and political speech.
Um,
and so I think the Way around that fight
is to agree free speech is the
fundamental value and nothing of the
reforms I support would like try to
restrict people's ability to speak.
What we're talking about is congressman
raising money.
We're not talking about inDividuals
speaking in the marketplaCe.
So you have a very loud voice.
Joe,
your voice is heard by millions and
nothing in our constitution should
permit the goVernment to be able to
suppress you at all,
so long as you're within the bounds of
decency or at least not decency because
that's not a bound boundary.
This thought guests obeys often,
but at least if you're not,
you know,
spreading false rumors and causing great
harm.
But the point is,
even though this free speech needs to be
protected,
we still should be able to focus on the
influence,
the economy of influence congressmen
live under when they spend 30 to 70
percent of the time sucking up to the
lesters to fund their campaigns.
That should be a focus of regulation
without the first amendment getting in
the way because we want to.
Congress filled with people who care
about what their voters want now with
their funders want the framers didn't
create a constitution to replicate an
aristocracy.
They were fighting and aristocracy.
They had a system where there was a
house,
the house of lords that had to ask the
aristocracy,
what do you want?
And everything could be blocked if the
aristocracy didn't like it.
Well,
we've replicated that system more
efficiently in America than they had
there.
Because we have a system where both the
house of representatives and the senate
is filled with people who are obsessed
with a single question what to my
funders want?
And if they can't answer that question
in a way that supports the legislation
and they're not going to support the
legislation,
or if it's important for them to block
they will block legislation.
And that's the dynamic of Washington
right now.
Francis fukuyama describes our
government as a veto ocracy veto ocracy.
And what he means by that is that
there's so many places were influenced.
Powerful influence can block the ability
of the government to do something that
it just can't do anything anymore.
And that's,
I think,
the consequence of allowing this
corruption of money to be so deeply
woven into our political system.
Is it possible to fix?
Yeah,
it is possible to fix because you know,
for,
for example,
hr one plus roca,
honda's bill all perfectly
constitutional.
You wouldn't have to amend the
constitution to do it.
I think that bill alone would solve 80
percent of the problem.
The possibility.
The problem isn't like conceiving of
what changes have to happen.
The question is how do you build the
political movement to get there?
And what that takes is leaders willing
to say,
we have to fix this corrupted democracy
first.
And leaders who stopped,
like pretending that we can get like a
christmas list of great changes in
government without fixing this democracy
first.
So,
you know,
bernie published last month in the
Washington post list of the 10 things
that should happen in the first hundred
days in the next democratic
administration.
10 great ideas.
Not a single one of those ideas address
the corruption of our political system.
You,
it was just,
it was just a christmas list of all the
things that the progressives want.
Did you know,
I'm a progressive.
I want some of those things.
But the point is like what things were
the,
well,
you know,
things like a trillion dollar
infrastructure project,
single pair healthcare free college,
um,
you know,
all things that bernie is pushing,
it has made so salad and things that I
think it's great that he has made sale
yet.
I mean,
he's a hero and like making these issues
central to at least the debate.
But what frustrates me is that instead
of focusing our anger on the
billionaires,
which he does,
we need to focus more anger on the
congressman,
the politicians,
which he does not.
I mean,
the guy's been in congress romas 30
years now,
and so it might be natural for him not
to notice that the people around him are
the problem.
Is it a natural thing or do you think
that he's possibly aware of the
consequences of stirring up that hornets
nest?
Because you know,
if anybody has a right to complain,
when the dnc conspired to rig the
primaries against him,
he's the number one guy.
He should be screaming from the
rooftops.
YoU're dealing with a corrupt system and
thiS is disgusting.
and he didn't.
He didn't do that,
and he didn't do that while hillary
clinton was running for president and he
knew it.
He knew he hAd been screwed out of the
primaries.
He knew they had conspired,
he knew it was all illegal,
and he kind of just kept his mouth shut.
Yeah,
well,
I think,
you know,
that was a responsibility.
I think that was a kind of.
I was a person reflecting on the
horrendous outcome if he took hillary
clinton down,
and so I think he restrained himself,
you know,
not perfectly.
I mean,
the fact is,
after it was clear he was not going to
be the nominee,
he still continued to talk about the
corruption around hillary,
which donald then picked up and turned
into a weapon against her.
But I think he,
he recognized,
you know,
as every responsible politician does
that,
you know,
it's not just about him,
it's about the future of America.
So when he restrained himself and didn't
want to take the whole system down,
then I get that.
But what I'm talking about now,
I'm talking about when you've got the
house of representatives talking about
fundamental reform,
it will be the first thing they take up.
We at least ought to have a presidential
campaign where candidates are saying,
hell yes.
The first thing we will do is to end the
corruption that makes it impossible for
this congress to function and stop
pretending like we can get all these
wonderful things given to us by santa
claus without fixing this first.
You gotta do the hard work of convincing
America that there is a solution because
you know,
the reality is,
I think most of America is where you
started this podcast.
Most of America thinks it's deeply
corrupted and there's nothing that can
be done.
They're half right.
It is deeply corrupted,
but it's not true.
There's nothing that can be done.
We can do something.
And in fact,
I think we can solve almost 80 percent
of it.
I still think there's constitutional
changes that might be necessary.
And I've been working like how do we get
constitutional changes and talking to
people.
My,
my podcast,
which of course has about one 1000th of
one,
1000000th of the people listening to
yours does.
But what is your podcast?
So people can listen to it.
It's another Way.
so season two is released today,
which is about an article five
convention,
but season one was about how to think
about the 2020.
Um,
but you know,
I,
I think that we might have to have
constitutional change anD I have been
supporting the efforts to think about
that.
But while we've got to do is to give
people a sense that there's something we
Can do before we amend the constitution.
You know,
we did a poll and found 96 percent of
americans believe it important to reduce
the influence of money in politics.
Ninety one percent didn't think it was
possible.
So that's the politics of resignation.
If you'd gone to Egypt under mubarak and
he'd start the average person in the
street and said,
you know,
what do you think?
I'm a bark.
They would've said,
you know,
we hate mubarak,
and then say,
well why aren't you doing anything about
it?
And they say,
because nothing can be done.
Or you know,
african americans in 1900 and America,
what do you think about jim crow?
We hate jim crow.
Why aren't you doing anything about it?
What?
Because there's nothing to be done about
it.
Well,
that's how americans think about this
political corruption.
They hate it.
They think it's deeply unjust,
inconsistent with what they thought
America was about.
But they don't do anything about it
because they don't think there's
anything to be done about it.
And that's where leaders have a role and
what we need our leaders running for
president right now to begin to explain
to people,
here's what we could do if only we built
the power to do it,
recognizing the most important
opposition here.
The lobbyist in wAshington are going to
be an incredibly difficult group to to
defeat,
but we can do that.
And if we do that,
every other issue becomes easier to
resolve in a sensible way.
Now there's no public support for
lobbyists,
right?
There's no,
there's no people out there that are
super psyched that lobbyists are out
there and exerting their influence on
our world.
But they obviously have enormous
financial backing behind them and they
have incredible influence in our,
in our culture.
But if you had some magic wand,
you could wave across this system and
fix it,
wouldn't removing lobbyists be one of
the first things that you would do?
No.
Why?
Why so?
Well,
because look,
you know,
congress,
especially in the current government,
legislates on a whole bunch of issues
that they don't have a clue about.
They don't know squat diddly about 99
percent of what they're legislating
amount.
They need information and one of the
other things gingrich did was to
completely macerate congress's own
information service.
They used to have a really powerful
information service to help congressmen
figure things out.
All of that's basically gone,
so they rely on outsiders to come in and
help them understand it.
Now my view is,
you know,
that's an imperfect system because
there's great inequality among the
quality of lobbyists,
but if all lobbyists were doing was
providing information like congressmen,
here's what's going to happen.
If you pass this bill,
like these jobs will disappear or this
lead will reappear in the water system
if that's all they were doing.
That's really valuable thing.
Information to the congress to help
congress decide what to do is an
essential part of making democracy work.
The part of lobbying that is the
corrupting part where they become the
mockers for the money,
not so much that they give it directly,
but you know,
they call their clients and they say,
you need everybody at the c level in
your corporation.
Descend $2,700
to this person and they steer it like
that when they become the kInd of source
of a resource for members of congress,
that's when they have thIs influence,
which is not related to their argument.
So you know,
I've met lobbyists who,
who hate the system as it is right now.
They'll say things like,
look,
I want a system where I win because my
ideas are good,
my arguments are better.
I don't want a system where I win
because I'm able to channel more money
than that guy because that's not a
democracy like at democracy should be.
These representatives are listening to
us and then they do the right thing
based on what they think helps their
constituents,
not how much they're going to raise if
they do this.
Over that.
How many lobbyists are there?
Oh man,
I can't answer that question.
You know,
one of the big problems we've got is
that the law has been weakened in
registering lobbyists.
So,
you know,
we have tens of thousands of people who
are functioning effectively of the
lobbyists but don't have to call
themselves lobbyists.
You have these members of congress who
go to government relations departments
and they oversee the government
relations department as long as they
don't go on to capitol hill and shake
hands,
but instead set up the meetings on
capitol hill with lower people,
shaking hands.
They're not called lobbyists.
So if you look at the lobbying numbers,
it looks like we peaked in lobbying
about three years ago and now are
declining,
but what that is in fact is that the
rules have been interpreted or allowed
to be unenforced so that many people who
are lobbyists actually aren't actually
functioning as lobbyists today.
So they are lobbyists,
but they don't wear the label is
lobbyists.
What do they call themselves?
Government relations people.
Experts.
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
and they aren't.
They say they're not technically
lobbyists.
And um,
you know,
I got into a huge fight with Scott
Brown.
You remember Scott Brown who ran a for
who was a senator in Massachusetts.
He ran under tea party ticket and it was
like this amazing republican to win as a
senator in Massachusetts.
And then Elizabeth Warren,
I'm defeated him in the,
in the,
in the election,
two years into his term,
he then went to Massachusetts to New
Hampshire and ran for senate and I was
helping a republican in New Hampshire
who was a reformer running for senate,
and we've referred to him as a lobbyist
and he went ballistic.
He saId,
I'm not a lobbyist,
and then he said,
I'm not technically a lobbyist.
He's a government relations person who's
like calling people on capitol hill.
He used to be with the senate trying to
get them to do things for him,
but he hasn't quite a technical labia,
so merely because the irs wouldn't refer
to them as a lobbyist,
he thought it was outrageous and fraud
for me to refer to them as what we all
know he is,
which is a lobbyist.
So lobbyists,
being a lobbyist is not defined by your
actions.
It's defined by your label.
It's defined by did you have to fill
something out to be alumni as well?
Once you are a lobbyist,
according to the law,
you've got all sorts of obligations of
reporting who you're spending your time
with.
What you're spending money on,
government relations,
people at a certain level that do
certain things aren't caught lobbyists,
but yet they have the exact same
function even more because they've got
tons of people working for them.
They can deploy in their,
in their work of doing lobbying.
How would that ever be?
How would you ever put a dam up there?
Well,
you know,
you only put a dam up there if you've
got the political will to make it
happen,
right?
You only get the political will to make
it happen.
If you have a political process that
focuses America on this deeply
corrupting problem and says,
god damn it,
we have to fix this,
and if you had that will,
if you said we're just going to fix
this,
and you had like the,
you know,
the geeks then go down the list of 25
things that have to happen to make it so
we have our congress is worried about
being representative of America as
opposed to representative of the lesters
in America.
We could do it.
it's not rocket science.
It really is not that hard.
You got to think carefully about what
kind of incentives you're producing.
I'm not saying it's obvious.
We're not going to sketch the full plan
here,
but it's possible it is constitutional
to do it and if we just built the
political will to to get there,
we could do it and the only way build
the political will.
It's really important right now because
right now people,
especially people like you need to be
saying to every one of the politicians
who is going to be sucking up to try to
be on your show to try to have a chance
to get their voice out the class a few
to the people who are listening to your
podcast.
It's important to people like you to
say,
okay,
what are you going to do about this
problem,
this problem in particular?
Is it a priority or is it like one of 12
things on your list?
I mean,
I imagine it's 11 for bernie or 12
somewhere,
but the question isn't,
isn't on the list because every one of
them is going to say,
yeah,
of course I support reform.
The question is,
are you going to bring America around so
that America thinks on day one,
this is what will happen.
Whatever else happens,
this is going to happen,
and my view is if there were a democrat
running for president who said,
look,
hold on,
we're going to fix this,
and the trumpers who were draining the
swamp,
you know the 25 percent of that base
that's drained the swamp is come with me
because that guy did not drain the
swamp.
That guy filled the swamp.
Swamp monsters are bigger and more and
more vital now than now than they ever
were,
but come with me.
We actually will do it.
I think there's a way to break this
election so that it becomes an election
about the unity around this recognition
rather than the disunity,
which is the screaming laughed against
the screaming,
right,
which is the way things.
Now we're evolving to a person on sit
down on the outside who doesn't have any
involvement in politics like myself.
It seemed so unbelievably complicated
that it is.
It exhausts you when you start examining
it and trying to pay attention to it and
how the system will works.
Correct me if I'm wrong,
but in the recent past,
there was something that was changed
that allows corporations to donate money
the same way that an individual would.
Right?
So in 2010,
the United States supreme court decided
a case called citizens united and
citizens united said that you couldn't
limit limit a corporation's ability to
spend money independently of a political
campaign,
so corporations not allowed to
contribute directly,
but that's not worth that much because
you're only allowed to give a total of
$5,400
to a candidate over the course of the
life of his campaign.
But what citizens united said is that
the constitution protects the right of
the corporation to engage in political
speech independent of a political
campaign.
So if you know,
if some congressmen is running for
congress,
exxon corporation can come in and spend
a million dollars to say why that
congressman is a good congressman or why
that congressmen the terrible
congressman,
but they have a constitutional right to
do that.
Now,
when that happened,
there are a bunch of us who were chicken
littles about this,
who said this is the end of democracy
because these corporations are just
going to spend unbelievable amounts of
money in the political process like
spending their money to effect the
results,
and that was not correct because what
happened is corporations quickly
discovered the high price of free
speech,
right?
So corporations like target back day,
uh,
anti gay candidate for governor and all
of a sudden found their stores being
picketed across the country because
people were furious that they would be
supporting such a candidate for
governor.
So corporates to quickly found that it's
not cheap to engage in political speech
in the marketplace.
They didn't want to do it like that.
Instead,
they wanted to find a way to channel
their money into dark money
organizations or into what evolved after
citizens united,
something called super pacs.
Super pacs were created not by the
supreme court.
Superpacs were created by a lower court
that said,
well,
if you can spend unlimited amounts of
money,
you should be allowed to give unlimited
amounts of money to an independent
political action committee.
That was the super pac supreme court has
never ruled on that question.
We have a case that we're taking up to
Alaska that's trying to appeal to the
supreme court to get them to actually
decide whether super pacs are mandated
by the constitution,
and what's different about this case as
the argument we're making is to the
conservatives.
What we're saying is the framers of our
constitution,
we're obsessed with corruption.
That was the issue they were
overwhelmingly trying to avoid and they
weren't focused on bribery.
They were focused on institutional
corruption.
These institutions.
It became unconnected to their purpose
representing americans and what our view
is is you know these conservatives on
the supreme court,
like neil gorsuch or justice thomas or
brett kavanaugh,
who say that we interpret the
constitution of the way the framers
would have interpreted it.
We're going to make the argument to
them,
which is there is no doubt the framers
of the constitution would have looked at
these super pacs and said,
these are an abomination.
These are outrageous from the
perspective of that democracy they were
trying to create and those justices
should at least one of them be willing
to stand up and defend the framers
values against this modern corruption
and if just one of them voted with the
four liberals who've already said they
think super pacs are an abomination,
then we could have a way to end the
superpacs in this system and that and
that would be an enormous benefit
because they've become so powerful,
but the courts alone can't save us.
Even If you ended superpacs tomorrow,
you still have lester land because the
super pacs are not what I was talking
about and less julian when I was talking
about less.
Julian was giving two candidates
directly and the small number of people
would still be giving two candidates
directly and the only way to solve that
is for congress to pass new laws.
That changed the way campaigns get
funded.
That's the sort of thing hr one is
trying to do as a sort of thing roca
honda's trying to do with.
That's the sort of thing that we don't
have a precedent to support right now.
We don't have democratic presidential
candidates who are making it the
champion issue right now and it won't
get done unless they do,
but it seems complicated to people when
you try to explain campaign finance and
you try to explain contributions to
candidates and contributions to sitting
senators and congressmen.
It's.
It's complicated and there's so many
different things to think about when
you're discussing this that to a person
who's on the outside,
well,
how do you fix this?
Well,
what are the laws now?
how did they get that way?
Well,
well,
well how about make it so they can't
give them money and there's all these
like real simplistic views of it from
the outside,
but it seems that it at the very least
limiting the amount of money that
someone's a lot.
Like what is the maximum amount of money
someone can give to a county
right now in the primary and the
general.
It's $5,400,
$2,700
in each and that goes up according to
inflation and that's pretty small
potatoes compared to what the super pacs
are doing,
reflection,
so you have these people running who
expect they're going to raise the money
to run their office from their direct
contributions,
but they're counting on the super pacs
to come in and spends ungodly amounts of
money like tens of millions of dollars
to support their candidate or to oppose
their up their opponent,
and so the supporters for those super
aren't even tiny.
There's are the adolfs in America.
People named adolf this tiny,
tiny,
tiny number of people who are
contributing to those to those things,
but you're right,
people.
Look,
there is no reason why most americans
should understand the complexities of
campaign finance law and they don't need
to.
What they need to ask is,
do we have a system of integrity in the
way we select representatives and if
you're,
if you're not brain dead in America,
you believe the answer to that question
is no.
We do not have a system of integrity.
There's no representational integrity.
It is corrupted in all the obvious raise
and like nobody should be forced to
study campaign finance in order to have
an entitlement to say,
hell,
hell no.
This system has got to end.
And so I think you're right.
If we,
you know,
people are forced to like articulate all
the 34 different changes that have to
happen.
We're never going to get there,
but let's not go there.
Let's just start and end with it is a
corrupted system and we want politicians
to fix it and if they don't fix it,
we'll throw them out until we get the
politicians who do.
And if we could build That as the
movement,
the recognition,
the core message of 20 slash 20,
I think there's a real shot because
we've primed the republican party.
There are a lot of people in that party
who are now so disgusted with the
corruption of the system.
Not necessarily mitch mcconnell,
he loves it,
but you know,
an ordinary republican voters and the
democrats have now committed themselves
to fixing this corrupted system.
This is the moment to do that and we
don't have to get into the details of
how much you should be allowed to
contribute to say there is a way to fix
this that would give us a representative
democracy,
maybe not again,
but for the first time wise,
mitch mcconnell,
so uniquely evil.
This guy has had it in his dna from the
first moment he went to Washington to
end any regulation of money in politics.
He engineered the selection of the fec,
the federal election commission
commissioners so that they would block
basically every enforcement action with
the ftc.
The fcc does nothing now because it's a
commission that has half republicans and
half democrats.
So if the republicans disagree from the
democrats,
then nothing gets done.
They can't enforce the most simple rules
anymore because mitch mcconnell is
populated the fec with people who don't
believe in campaign finance rules.
He said,
citizens united this decision that said
corporations could give unlimited
amounts of money to independent
political speaking says one of the
greatest decisions of the supreme court.
And he said he was gonna fight like hell
to defend it.
And when this proposed hr one was raised
to him,
mitch mcconnell said,
there's not a chance in hell this will
ever even get a debate in the senate.
This man is obsessed with the idea that
money should have the power in
Washington that it has right now.
And people are talking about reforming
it are the enemy.
And so you.
The thing about mitch mcconnell is he's
actually an incredibly smart man and
he's an incredibly smart strategist and
he's been playing this game for a long
time.
Um,
and um,
and I think he's like responsible for 85
percent of the judicial structure that
makes it possible for this to be
blocked.
There's an amazing series to debates
happened 20 years ago between john
mccain and mitch mcconnell.
So this was when congress was passing
something called the mccain feingold
law,
which was the last great effort to deal
with this problem.
And it was flawed and a bunch of ways,
but it was an important success.
Mitch mcconnell,
I'm stood on the floor of the senate and
said,
mr mccain says that,
uh,
the senate,
we can't say mr again.
So the senator from Arizona has said
that the system is corrupt.
I want him to name the corrupt people,
and mccain stands up and says,
I'm not talking about particular
individuals.
I'm talking about the system.
It's the system's corrupt.
And then mcconnell,
almost clueless.
I said,
if the system's corrupt,
there must be corrupt people.
If there's not corrupt people,
then the system's not corrupt.
So the only corruption he could imagine
was corruption where somebody was taking
a bribe,
and if that's the only corruption we're
allowed to remedy,
then the whole system of influence we
have right now is not to be touched.
But you know,
I think mccain's point was you can have
a system filled with lots of honor's
congress people and lots of honest
senators who never engage in bribery,
but they know how to bob and weave and
bend and speak and say the right things
to attract the right kind of money.
And that's as much corruption as bribery
is.
And mccain's view was we had to end it.
So he was the last great republican
fighter for reform of this corrupted
system.
There'd been many,
before barry goldwater was an incredibly
vocal opponent to the role of money in
politics,
but I think what we have to do is to
find a way to revive that and to
leverage from this president's assertion
that this is a corrupt system and we
have to change the system into actually
building the political power to make
that change happen.
Another thing that's very weird is it
every four years or so,
there's this cry to eliminate the
electoral college.
Every four years ago,
people realized that the battleground
states are so critical and that so much
money is being spent on the small
handful of states because they give you
all the electoral votes and this is how
you win an election,
and then people say,
well,
why is that?
That doesn't make any sense.
It should be one person,
one vote.
Are we really that divided as a nation
that we need to isolate ourselves into
these small little lines in the dirt
where this part is worth this amount and
that parts worth that amount.
And so everybody plays this weird
electoral college game and then you get
a situation like what just happened
where hillary clinton wins the popular
vote,
but it's not the president because the
electoral college is what makes
everything.
Yeah.
So the way you just described this
problem is exactly.
The people have to think about it.
The problem isn't.
I mean,
it is a bad thing that the loser wins.
That's just not the way elections
supposed to work.
So that's happened twice in our
lifetime.
Um,
and uh,
it happened 100 years before that.
And it's going to happen more frequently
going forward.
We can show that demographically,
but that's not the real problem.
The real problem is that in every
election,
the presidential candidates are focused
on just 14 states.
The battleground states,
the purple states and those 14 states
are the only states that matter to those
candidates.
And what scholars have demonstrated as
the presidents and campaigns bend to
themselves and their policies to make
those states happy.
And those states don't represent
America.
They're older,
they're wider.
They're industry is kind of 19th century
industry.
There are seven and a half times the
number of people in America working in
solar energy as mine coal,
but you never hear about solar energy In
a presidential campaign because those
people live in California and Texas.
They don't matter to the presidential
election,
which you hear about his coal mining
because the 50,000
coal miners left in America happened to
live in these battleground states.
So this is just a product of the way the
electoral college or the way states
count their votes to allocate their
electors.
Something called the winner take all
system.
So all but two states say that the
winner of the popular vote gets all of
the electoral votes for that state.
So you know,
in 2000 in Florida,
George Bush won that state based on a
stop to recount by 531 votes.
He goT all the electoral college votes
in that state even though he just barely
won that state.
And so winner take all is what makes it
so that it doesn't make sense for
anybody to pay.
Pay any attention to any of the non
battleground states and penn,
all of your tiMe in the battleground
states in 2016,
99 percent of campaign spending was in
14 states,
90,
99 percent,
95 percent of time,
But the only reason they were not 99
percent in those battleground states as
the other five percent.
They were in New York and California
raising money.
RighT?
So,
so this is a system designed to give
power to these battleground states.
And then you say,
well,
why is it something the constitution
requires?
And the answer to that is absolutely
not.
The constitution does not say how the
states will allocate their electors,
and indeed when states started adopting
this winner take all system,
many thought it was an outrageous
perversion of the constitutional design.
So jeff to jefferson was outraged,
but then he said,
well,
some states are going to do it.
Then all states have to do it.
Because if you're a state that allocates
all of your electrodes to the winner,
you're going to have more power than
your neighboring states.
You only gets half the electrodes to the
winter.
So very quickly there was a race to the
bottom and that's kind of where it's
stuck.
And so the question is now what we can
do about it.
Well,
there are two big reform efforts out
there.
One of them is called the national
popular vote compact.
I mean I should say,
you know,
you can imagine amending the
constitution,
but it takes three fourths of the states
to change the constitution.
And three fourths of the states are not
going to agree with abolishing the
electoral college.
So this is not going to happen anytime
soon through the constitution.
But there are two ways.
Without amending the constitution,
we could fix this problem.
Won the national popular vote pro.
A compact is basically states who say,
look,
we're going to pledge our electors to
the winner of the national popular vote.
So the state looks at who won the
national popular vote,
and then picks the slate of electors
from their state with a party of the
person who won the national popular
vote.
So in a state like New York,
if the republican won the national
popular vote,
even though most people in New York are
democratic,
they would allocate their electrodes to
the republican vice versa in Texas.
That's,
that's the way that system would work.
And you know,
I personally liked the system because I
believe in the idea of one person,
one vote,
everybody's vote is an american citizen
for the american president should be
equal.
It shouldn't,
shouldn't matter that you're having to
live in Wyoming versus Pennsylvania
versus New York.
Um,
but there are people who are worried
about this because they fear that it'll
become a kind of flyover democracy.
But the only places that candidates will
care about will be places like la or New
York or chicago.
I actually don't think that's right,
but I get the understanding,
I think they're wrong about the way the
campaigns work,
but I understand why they're anxious
about it.
So then that leads to the alternative
solution,
which is something,
you know,
my group equal citizens.us
is litigating this right now.
Um,
we're just trying to declare this winner
take all system,
violates the constitution.
Because it basically says that if you're
a republican in California,
your vote never matters.
If you're a democrat in Texas,
your vote never matters because we just
count your vote up and then we throw it
away because we allocate all the
electors to the dominant party in your
state.
And so we've got david boies is our
chief litigate,
or we've got a case in California,
Texas,
South Carolina and Massachusetts asking
the courts to declare a winner take all
unconstitutional and instead say that
electrons have to be allocated
proportionally.
So if you get 40 percent of the vote in
the state,
you get 40 percent of the electorate.
If you get 50 percent,
you get 50 percent of doctors.
And what that would do overnight is it
would make every state in the nation
competitive.
Like there'd be a reason for a democrat
to go to Texas because you're not going
to get all the electoral votes.
You're not going to get a half the
electoral votes,
but you'll get 40 percent,
maybe 45 percent.
And that could matter.
Um,
or a republican would go to California
because,
you know,
you're not going to get all the votes in
California,
but you're going to get a lot.
There are a lot of republicans in
California,
um,
so this change would immediately make
every state in play.
But unlike the national popular vote
alternatives,
there are many people who look at this
and say,
this will be better because small states
would still have a pretty important role
like an elector as an elector.
And if I can get it from Arizona,
I'm going to care about Arizona if I can
get it from Arkansas,
care about Arkansas.
Um,
so it's not going to just be the big
states are the big population centers.
It's going to be every state.
And so if we can get,
you know,
a court to say this violates the
constitution and then you could have
states forest to allocate their electors
proportionally.
And if they did that and then the
problem that you identified at the
start,
which I think is the problem could be
solved overnight.
You would no longer have these
battleground states deciding everything
you'd ever president.
Who cares about getting elected by all
of America and that would be incredible
improvement though that seems like in,
in and of itself would be a game changer
if they could do that,
that would change a lot.
But one of the things that you said,
uh,
you said you don't think that it's
possible that we would ever vote out the
electoral college,
but is there a support for the electoral
college?
Is there a good argument for it?
So there is support for the idea that
everY state have a role and there's a
support for the idea that small states
get to kind of thumb on the scale,
which is what the electoral college
does.
So there is some supportive,
but most people,
you know,
70 percent of people don't like the idea
that the president is not chosen from
the majority of voters.
So most people would oppose it.
But the point is to change the
constitution,
you need the state legislatures or state
conventions to agree with the change.
And what many states,
at least thIrteen states I fear would
say,
is that we actually win more under this
system.
Then we lose,
so we're not going to change the system,
and so unless you get like some
overwhelmingly popular movement to
support it,
or again,
you know,
you can imagine a presidential candidate
who kind of made fixing this part of the
democracy part of the plan too.
I don't see how you're going to build a
political movement to get there or
another way of putting it.
As you know,
this national popular vote compact,
which is going around state to state and
getting states to join right now has
about a hundred.
And so the way this works is that when
the equivalent of 270 electoral votes
have been committed than the compact
kicks in.
So when they get to 270,
the problem goes away.
You know the problem of this electoral
college goes away because add to 70,
according to the plan,
the winner of the popular vote wins the
electoral college.
They right now have 172 electors
pledged,
right?
So they have less than 100 more to go.
But the problem is they've got to
convince states to join the compact and
they're kind of.
They kind of hit this red wall now
because many republicans thing,
the only way to win the presidency is
through the electoral college.
Now,
so many state legislatures,
why do they believe that?
I think many republicans just think that
they're great benefit is from the
electoral college.
It's not surprising because the
battleground states are primarily
republican because the base number of
republican states is sell high.
Right?
Because you know,
these small rural states get
disproportionately more electors than
states.
Like California.
Wyoming gets three electors
disproportionate in terms of the
population.
right?
so they liked the system as it is.
And you know,
you look back and you say,
well they got George Bush,
even though he didn't win the national
vote and they got Donald Trump,
vote,
it's not hard for me to understand why
they're there.
I think,
again,
I don't think they're right about this.
You know,
in 2004,
if 50,000
votes had switched to john kerry in
Ohio,
then john kerry would have won the
electoral college but lost the popular
vote and if that had happened in 2004,
I think the electoral college would be
dead today because a republican won in
2000 a democrat,
ron in 2004 people would say,
this system is just crazy.
We got to get rid of this system,
but now people think,
well,
republicans benefit from this,
so I'm a republican.
I'm going to block the change.
And if that's true,
then it's never going to happen at a
constitutional level because the
constitution requires three fourths of
the states to support the reform and the
reinforcement of the as the Donald Trump
one without having the popular one.
Yeah.
And you know,
of course not.
There's no hypocrisy that touches this
president.
But remember,
in 2012,
when there was a moment for about 10
minutes when the national media was
reporting that,
that romney was going to win the popular
vote,
but barack obama was going to be elected
by the electoral college.
Trump started tweeting vigorously about
how this is a denial of democracy.
We have to march on Washington to end
this banana republic like system because
the electoral college was the worst
possible thing in the world.
And of course after 2016 he had
different views about the electoral
college.
Um,
I wasn't old enough to understand what
was going on during watergate.
Uh,
what Year was that?
Well,
70.
Uh,
so,
you know,
the break In happens in the lead up to
the 72 election.
and then he eventually resigned after
that.
But this is our watergate this moment
right now.
And cohen's going to go to jail for
three years.
And I mean,
he's testifying against trump and all
these people are testifying and they're
calling him.
What do they call him?
Coconspirator number one is that with
the individual official individually.
Number one,
this is a very unusual moment for us to,
to be watching this all unfold and to
see this slow dissection,
what mueller seems to be doing is like
slowly closing off all the escape routes
and slowly circling the troops around
this one area that he's trying to,
that he's,
that he's attacking.
Yeah.
So,
um,
he's a brillianT tactician.
Yeah.
and,
uh,
and so I think it's that
the worst for Donald Trump has yet to
come.
Um,
and I do think the parallel is
watergate,
but there's a really important
difference here,
you know.
Um,
so I'm old enough to remember watergate.
I was like 12 or 13 minutes happened and
my uncle happened to be the lawyer who
worked in the house of representatives
convincing the house of representatives
to vote the articles of impeachment.
So he and that weekend when nixon
resigned,
he came to visit us.
We lived in the Kentucky part of
Pennsylvania,
that kind of right wing,
middle part of the state.
He came to visit us and,
um,
he told me this was gonna happen and uh,
that was the event.
That was the weekend that I decided I
wanted to become a lawyer.
Um,
but,
uh,
but the big difference between these two
times is that when that happened,
the way most people got access to news
was three television networks every day
they watched the news at the same time
because there was nothing else on.
And those three television networks kind
of shot right down the middle and told
the story as they saw it.
Um,
you know,
it was kind of the walter cronkite era
of news.
And as this story broke,
they just reported it as they saw it.
And as they saw it,
it was a pretty damning indictment of
the precedent.
And what's amazing is he walked the
polling among republicans and their
support for the president six months
before the president resigns.
The poll says,
among republicans,
he has about an 83 percent support rate.
And then when he resigns,
his support rate among republicans is
about 50 percent.
And that's because the news,
newspapers and television had like told
everybody the same story and americans
hearing the same story.
It came to the same view that there was
something deeply corrupted by this
president and he had to go,
we don't live in that news environment
today.
We live in an environment where half of
America lives in one news world and the
other half of America lives in another
news world and the half of America
living in the breitbart fox news world
are not being told the stories that the
people living in the msnbc,
npr,
news universe are.
And so in this world,
the opportunity for americans to like
see the facts,
the same facts and have a reflective
judgment about it and come to a view
that this president on a needs to resign
or be impeached.
I don't think he should be impeached,
but let's,
that's a separate question.
Um,
is,
is not possible.
and that's what's so terrifying about
it.
When you live in a democracy where we
don't all live in the same universe,
you know,
we don't know the same facts.
Um,
how do you knit together a public that
can address these critical issues of
national import?
Um,
and,
and that's,
I think our biggest challenge,
right?
Well,
it gets grayer than that,
right?
With characters like sean hannity that
they separate the line between not just
being some sort of a political pundit,
but actually campaigning for the
president,
showing up at speeches,
uh,
addressing
the crowd making,
making these big statements in support
of the president is very strange to
watch because I don't remember that at
any point in time.
No,
it wasn't the past.
But I think the thing we need to realize
is it is the future because it pays
cable news pays tremendously when these
people become partisan hacks inside of a
politics of hate,
which is the current politics of like
both the democratic and republican
parties and the cable news stations.
They build tribes who are deeply loyal
to them.
And the loyalty to those tribes
translates into advertising dollars.
It is the business model of cable.
So sean hannity looks to old geezers
like me,
like an abomination from the perspective
of what news should be like.
But from the standpoint of what the
future is going to be,
he is the future.
And so then it becomes a question like,
how do we knit together a democracy
given there will be people like the sean
hannity's on cable television.
uh,
and you know,
I've began to talk about the slow
democracy movement,
which I think,
you know,
I think I pointed to you as part of
that.
I think that there's a need to begin to
think about how do we build political
understanding,
not through broadcast television but
through something else that gives people
a chance to think in more than 32nd
bites.
Yes.
and podcasting I think is a core part of
that.
Is it entirely possiBle that something
could be profitable that does shoot down
the middle because people are so tired
of this cnn,
fox,
bipolar distribution of information.
I mean,
I remember when the elections were going
on,
I would flip back and forth between the
two channels and it was like two
alternative universes.
There are different worlds,
different worlds of focus,
different worlds of the,
what they're projecting.
Yeah.
So,
buT I don't think the point is that it
has to be down the middle.
I think it has to be deep.
So this is what I think is so powerful
about podcasting,
like you know,
the fact that you get people to listen
to,
you talk about an idea for an hour or
two hours,
some of them three hours is astonishing,
literally astonishing in an age where
the most a cable news channel will
allocate to a new store is a minute and
a half,
two minutes,
three minutes.
Right?
And you know,
in the context of the tweet,
thinking of cable news,
they can't afford to go deep on anything
and everything they're going to talk
about are the things they can talk about
sensibly in 25 seconds or 30 seconds or
40 seconds.
And what,
you know,
because you've lived this life of like
having deep conversations about things
that are important is that it sometimes
takes more than 30 seconds to understand
something always.
Yeah.
And the point is if we have media that's
focused at the 32nd chunk and that's how
America understands the issues.
We're never gonna get anywhere and the
only way to get to get someplace is to
begin to have conversations that are at
the hour long chunk or the two hour long
chuck,
and it's not important that that be
neutral or balanced.
I don't care if it's balanced.
I care that it is attempting to be
serious and in depth understanding the
issue,
so I don't care if keto wants to have
podcasts,
they try to tell us the deep story of
iron randy and economics or something
like that.
That's fine.
That's good.
I think it's important that people start
thinking about these issues in a richer,
deeper way and I think the challenge we
have now is how do we begin to produce
understanding,
realizing that the world of walter
cronkite is never coming back and it
might be a good thing,
but it is just never coming back.
And the world of sean hannity is a world
that will destroy democracy.
So how do we rebuild democracy outside
of that and you know,
if you.
If you had to pick the three things that
have the most hopeful,
I think podcasting is number one.
I think some of the reflective,
deep,
you know,
funny,
playful,
but in the end,
at the end of the hour long segment of a
podcast,
you understand something you didn't
understand before.
I think that's number one.
I think comedy like comedy television,
like brings pEople into understanding
things in a way that's not possible on
fox news.
I think that,
you know,
as number two I think shows like
homeland.
I don't know if you watch homeland,
watched it until the redheaded guy died
and then that went through this dark
period in the middle,
but the recent seasons or just unfucking
believable and because they're
unbelievable because they are such a
deep rich understanding of the tensions
at issue.
Like you won't understand the Iran
nuclear deal watched the last season
because after watching that season,
you like understand the tensions between
the cia and the president and what's
actually going on with Israel.
and,
and I think that if you imagine
television shows aspiring to tell the
story in an entertaining way and in a
way that brings people in,
that they voluntarily want to watch it.
But that in the end,
at the end of watching a season,
you understand something,
I understand the current season's about
the Russia,
you know,
struggle and I can't wait to watch it
because it's going to be a richer
understanding of that story than
anything on television.
Did you watch house of cards?
I did up until the season.
Did you quit at this season?
I watched the season.
I was very disappointed by watched
episode one and I said this,
it seems like they gave it to some
different writers and it's this
craziness.
It just seemed like a.
Like somebody just got ahold of it and
they said,
I'll take it and I want to write it my
own way.
Right.
But even in the very beginning,
you know,
the striking thing about house of cards
is it made it seem like stuff actually
could happen in Washington.
Yes.
And you're like,
wow,
that's really powerful guy.
Frank underwood actually can actually
get important bills passed.
And I remember watching that same.
Holy shit.
This is just completely not the truth.
This is just not the way the system
works.
I mean,
it would be good if it worked like that
because at least it could do stuff,
but the way it actually works is that
these guys would be scurrying around
trying to figure out,
you know,
what the tentacles of funders are
directing them to do and the tentacles
of funders added together would be don't
do anything.
That's not what you're there to do.
But what it did is sort of highlight the
influences these people experience and
it showed how deeply entrenched
everything is.
Yeah.
I mean I don't want to talk it down at
all,
man.
I want a million different things like
this on television.
Just something that gives people just
give them a richer understanding.
Well,
an understanding period because for the
most part,
what people,
when you go to school,
you learn about democracy and our system
of representative government and then
you become an adult and you forget most
of what you learned and then you hear
something about the electoral college
and the popular vote and you know,
and then you see bills getting passed
and you know,
what the hell is that and this and the
stuff you learn at school is so
politically correct.
IT can't actually give you an
understanding of anything.
Like you actually taught kids in high
school the way congress worked.
You know,
the school board would go crazy and
they're like,
no,
no.
You can't talk down american democracy
like that.
So the truth is not teachable.
The only way to get people to see the
truth is to expose it to them in a way
that they want to see it.
And you know,
my point is that's not going to be fox
news.
Fox news can never cover it at the depth
and the interest level that it needs to
be covered.
It's going to be things like what you do
or things like what great television can
do is our system of government analogous
to like taking like dos or windows 95 or
something like that and just continuing
to patch it and never revisit it and
never come up with a new operating
system.
I think the better analogy is an
operating system that has been taken
over by malware virus because it's not
innocent,
you know,
dos,
it was a fun system and that like
cranked to a halt after awhile when
you're trying to pile more and more on
top of it.
But that was just kind of the limits of
what it could do.
There was nothing malicious in its
failure,
but,
but there's something malicious in this
failure.
There are people who are eagerly focused
on how to make sure our government can't
govern because if our government can't
govern,
they win.
So you know,
the koch brothers have this amazing
diverse bipolar character.
On the one hand,
they're talking about the ideals of
government,
but the reality is their interventions
make it so we don't have an epa that can
regulate their companies.
So basically we have environmental
policy that leaves their companies
alone,
which means they can make tons of money
by polluting our environment without
ever having to pay the consequence of
it.
And what they want is not change of a
particular kind except for tax cuts.
What they want is nothing to happen.
Um,
and so that's the kind of malware that's
taken over the system of our government
has blocked the ability to government to
function.
and rather than having leaders at the
center who say,
hold it,
let's just pause for a second and
realize this is a fucking broken system.
We have politicians that continue to
pretend as if everything's working,
you just have to elect more democrats
and we'll get what we want,
you know,
I'm voting online.
What would be the pitfalls of that and
why hasn't that been implemented?
If you can bank online,
why can't you vote online?
So I think,
you know,
most of the tech,
the experts who are disinterested,
meaning they're not working for default
or something like that,
I would tell you that we don't yet have
the infrastructure to be able to be
confident about this.
Now,
there are lots of people working on,
I think really great open source
implementations that that could be,
could eventually produce the kind of
confidence that we need to have to be
able to vote online.
And so I don't foreclose it in the long
run.
But I think what we've seen in the short
run is that when we turn to these
proprietary providers of technology to
enable us to vote,
they give us shit.
Uh,
you know,
look,
look at these voting machines.
There was a recent story about his 11
year old who was able to,
uh,
within like 15 minutes hack into the
Florida election,
um,
uh,
system and change the results from a,
you know,
one,
one candidate to another.
Um,
because you know,
the companies that build these
technologies are not filled with a bunch
of rocket science.
Like if you're really good,
you're going to go work for google or
for facebook or something like that.
So.
So the proprietary software has all of
these bugs and holes and intended back
doors built into it.
Intended back towards.
Yeah,
because they need,
you know,
the company itself needs a simple way to
get into check or to fix things,
but then they worry about the fact that
other people will get back doors to be
able to get.
This was the argument for diebold system
that did have a third party entrance.
Tons of allegations about that.
Did you ever see the documentary hacking
democracies?
Is that disturbing to you?
Incredibly.
I don't know how much I believe about it
was a well because I've seen so much
that contradicts some of the claims
about the extent to which there was real
differences in the numbers.
I remember at that election really being
anxious about it because it seemed to me
in Ohio in particular,
a really compelling case was made that
there was some something weird going on,
but you know,
the point is not so much the particulars
of a particular election.
It's recognizing that if you turn this
over to proprietary software companies
who are going to build these closed
systems,
nobody can inspect.
There's no reason to trust them and you
know,
they think they are intending to make
themselves vulnerable to the russians.
They're just going to make themselves
vulnerable to the russians and there are
alternative systems like open source
systems.
It's something I know some people are
building right now that I think
eventually could get us there.
An open source system like linux based,
something that would go onto your phone.
Well it could be on your phone,
but the point about the open source is
that anybody can inspect the
and be confident that the code is doing
what it says.
It's true,
right?
What I'm saying about being on your
phone as the biometrics that we use on
our phone today or some of the most
secure in terms of like being able to
establish that it's you that's making
that vote like iris scanners that you
have on the.
I have a samsung note,
nine that has an iris scanner,
checks my eyeballs.
You know,
you're my iphone checks my face.
takes the shit,
I mean,
there's,
they're pretty amazing fingerprints
obviously,
but the fact that this is probably in
terms of our own personal security in
terms of information,
this is probably the most secure.
Our smartphones are probably the most
secure devices we've ever possessed.
So on the one hand,
yes,
and that's why I say I agree with you
that in the long run we should imagine a
world where to be trivially easy to
vote,
just like it's easy for me to venmo you
or a cash app,
you,
I guess it's your favorite here.
Um,
uh,
money that should be the way the future
is.
But on the other hand,
we need to realize that these
technologies are also incredibly
insecure in the sense that there is now
a commercial market to exploit a
insecurities inside of these phones.
And,
uh,
you know,
these companies basically have bounties
that they post on the web,
right?
For people who will come forward and
find certain holes and hacks.
And once they get those hacks,
they use them to leverage power.
And governments play this game all the
time.
And you know,
there's a pretty strong argument that
the murder was a product of one of these
exploits which was then going to be
revealed and the need to cover up the
fact that there was such an exploit out
there.
What is this?
I didn't know this.
What is this about?
What's.
So the basic idea is that,
that,
you know,
these companies and many of them,
um,
most prominent ones here,
israeli companies who facilitate the
ability of governments to buy access to
your phone,
right?
And the standard way in which this has
done is to,
is to pierce the security by sending you
something that you click on it,
it then embeds itself in the phone.
And there's no way you see it in a way
that it can be blocked.
But there's,
there's rumors now that in fact we've
got something more than that going on
where all they need to do is get your
telephone number and they're able to
hack into the system to get access to
your phone.
But the point is these companies have a
market now for selling this type of
insecurity.
So like,
sell the ability for you to get access
here and the story that,
you know,
I don't have a lot of reasons to,
to,
to be absolutely confident about this
except that I trust the person who's
inside the security world that says this
to me.
Um,
you knoW,
the story is that this is part of what
happened in the [inaudible] context,
that the saudis have exploited this in a
way that was going to be revealed.
And,
and the simple solution to that eventual
revelation was to remove the person who
would reveal it.
And that's why.
Yeah.
So,
so this,
the point about the recognize at these
funds on the one hand for the ordinary
life,
it's more secure than anything you've
ever had,
but in the other hand,
systematically it's building insecurity
into our lives in a way that can be
exploited by powerful people.
And for most people,
doesn't matter.
Like most people,
ordinary,
ordinary joes,
uh,
you know,
they're not,
they're never going to be vulnerable
because nobody's going to spend a
million dollars to get a hack against
the individual person.
When I hear that from a person
justifying why they don't worry about
it,
it drives me crazy.
I can't do anything.
What are they going to do?
I'm a clean,
don't worry about me,
but it's not.
That's not what we're doing when we're
talking about right?
Because if we have a system where
systematically powerful people can just
push a button and like find a way to
control,
you can control anybody jamal custodian,
then we've got a system that no longer
makes it possible for ordinary people to
stand up to power.
That's,
that's basically what it is.
Like this is the,
this is a structure that allows powerful
people if it is insecure to protect
themselves because they can just
leverage that against us.
And I think,
you know,
this is a completely an focused problem.
Like nobody is talking about this
politically,
but the market for this commercialized x
security exploits is hugely important
and we've got to find a way to,
to address it.
So is it feasible that as technology
advances and as the security advances as
well,
I mean the biometrics that we have today
are far greater than the passwords that
we use just a few years ago,
that there could be something that you
can't exploit,
especially considering open source
variance where they can be checked by
the community.
Yeah.
So,
so,
so the problem is,
is not the kind of particular
technologies working the way you intend
them to work.
You know,
if you've got great biometric
technologies,
those are really good at making sure in
the ordinary case that you're the right
person using your phone.
The problem iS the code is so big and so
complicated that there's always going to
be little bugs inside the code and what
these exploits are are like coders who
like poke at the code looking for these
little hooks and they link one hook to
another hook to another hook and then
they find the way in to exploit the
system.
So the exploits are never.
Well I shouldn't say never.
there's another story.
It's important to recognize.
I'll talk about that a second,
but the exploits are not in the main
case intended by anybody.
It's just the un.
It's just the natural consequence of
having,
you know,
literally hundreds or millions of lines
of code that go into making this machine
work and that's what's beinG exploited.
And when you have a world like the
iphone,
which is mono culture,
like,
you know,
everybody has the same operatinG system
where it seemed versions of the
operating system,
if you find
an exploit in the,
in the ios and apple doesn't know about
it,
um,
and you can exploit it for six months or
a year.
You can do a lot of damage to a lot of
people's lives before anybody gets
around to,
to blocking it.
Now,
you know,
that's even in the best case where
everybody's working hard to make their
system as secure as it can.
It can be,
you know,
there was this period after the nine
slash 11 when there's,
you know,
very strong and credible allegations
that the United States government went
around to these technology companies and
said,
we need you to build back doors into
your technology.
So we can track down the terrorists and
there's strong allegations that in fact
many of the most important technology
companies complied and what they quickly
discovered is that the backdoor is
intended for the United States
government trying to attack terrorists
were being exploited by the chinese
trying to steal trade secrets from
american company.
So this infrastructure that was intended
to be secure to protect american
companies so that they could do their
work without being asked for an
espionage on top of them became an
infrastructure of espionage again
because it's so complicated to get it
perfectly right.
And,
um,
the return from exploit is so huge that
you can just expect the market is always
going to supply it.
What was the other example that you're
going to bring up that was,
that was the idea was that the intended
backdoors that turn out to be exploited
for other purposes,
but isn't the system itself like when
you deal with the hanging chads or pay
terrible,
their counters ridiculous.
You're living giving it up to human
beings.
The potential for errors.
Massive,
right?
Just to count things up or the potential
for corruption.
The decision to ignore certain
collections,
I mean this,
this has all been documented,
right?
Yeah,
and all of this follows from the fact
that we,
bizarrely in America,
unlike most mature democracies around
the world,
make the running of elections a partisan
event like,
you know,
republicans in a district or democrats
in a district control the voting
systems.
Like why the hell would that be?
Why don't we have like people who,
who self identity and professional
framework is nonpartisan,
independent,
like election commission.
That's about,
you know,
it's above the partisan bow so that
there's no incentive in Georgia,
for example,
for the government to allocate money to
fix voting machines just in republican
districts and not in democratic
districts or there's no incentive to
shut down a voting polling place,
which they did in Georgia,
making it so that people in that area
would have to go huge distance to be
able to vote,
were to create it so that it takes seven
hours to vote in some districts and 20
minutes to vote in other districts.
There's no incentive to do that if your
job is simply to make it possible for
people to vote efficiently and if we
measure you and,
and,
and reward you based on how easy have
you made it for people in this state,
devote easily and efficiently.
We don't get that kind of efficiencY.
We don't get that kind of innovation
because it's a rigged game.
You,
you know,
you might have people who,
I'm sure many of these people are above
partisan motivation,
but we also know that many of these
people are deeply motivated by partisan
politics,
especially at that kind of middle level
of party politics.
And if theY can set it up so that their
side winds because of the way they've
played the game for allocating voting
resources,
then more power to them.
And that'S exactly what happened in
Georgia with this recent governor's
election.
That kind of outrageous that the man
running the election system,
secretary of state does not resign from
this job as he runs for governor.
And the governorship is decided in such
a very close way by,
um,
the decisions that he made about how
they're going to throw people off.
The voting roles are which allocations
of voting system technology will be made
across the state.
This is a product or just making it
political.
we could make it non political and might
not have all of these kinds of problems
dealing with this very unique landscape
now of google and facebook and twitter
And instagram and all these different
social media groups that have a vested
interest in a specific narrative being
portrayed.
And spi.
One thing specifically is,
and this is being addressed right now in
congress,
is the discrimination against
conservative voices and there's a lot of
denial that.
But there's also a lot of evidence that
that is the case and that they feel like
they have some moral or ethical
obligation to suppress certain
conservative voices for whatever reason
and push the narrative of,
of progressive and liberal voices.
This is a very strange thing because
the,
the amount of influence that something
like google or facebook has today is
arguably as great or greater than the
sean hannity's of the world and the cnns
and the,
the,
the traditional news outlets.
yeah.
So no doubt.
There's a big debate about whether they
were more important in 2016 than the
cable stations.
My colleague yoke,
benkler has a book that argues pretty
powerfully.
I think that it was actually the cable
stations that were more responsible for
the result then the facebooks,
but whether in 2016 they are,
the more powerful someday in the future,
they are going to be more powerful.
Certainly powerful.
Absolutely.
Um,
and you know,
the question is what we mean by bias or
discrimination here.
Like,
you know,
in 2017 in the fall it was revealed that
facebook was selling ads for people who
wanted to target quote jew haters.
Okay.
So you could go and you could buy ads
for jew haters.
Now there was never.
How did that work?
Okay.
No,
I mean,
you know,
they have lots of categories you get to
pick when you buy facebook ads,
you know,
liberals or people who people over 60
white armor.
This was one of the categories that was
exposed.
You could buy ads for jew haters.
There was an actual category.
Yeah,
yeah.
What?
Yeah.
Now there was never a time that a
facebook engineer or a marketing person
decided we ought to create a jew hater
category.
Right.
This is not a decision of any human.
It was the product of the machine,
the ai that was developing the
categories based on what they saw people
happen to be interested in and then
throw up categories to see what sticks
and then certain categories stick and
then they run with them.
So it.
So you might say,
you know,
if you were the,
anti defamation league,
you would say,
oh my god,
facebook is discriminating to encourage
jew haters.
But from another perspective,
you're like the machines doing it,
no doubt.
But,
uh,
but to what extent do you want to say
facebook is doing it?
And I Think that's off.
That's often what you're going to see in
this argument about whether they're
quote biasing the system against one
side or the other,
you know,
like this hilarious a hearing that was
just held on capital hill two days ago
where a great congressman lewis,
like if you don't want negative ad
results in the suit,
then don't do bad things.
So then,
um,
so,
you know,
I think this is quite fun.
It was really funny.
It,
this is like nobody's intent.
We should just explain that to people
who don't know what we're talking about.
Yeah.
So,
so there was an argument about whether
google was tilting the ads to embarrass
one side or the other and uh,
I guess it was a congressman from Iowa,
everybody like that.
That's the guy who didn't know that
google didn't make the iphone.
Yeah,
he got embarrassed.
But anyway,
there was thIs,
um,
you know,
the exchange was basically here I'm
going to show you a demonstration and
they put it in a certain name and
congressman smith and then up comes this
are referenced to his race baiting and
he's like,
outraged by this and you know,
so one theory is you've got google
engineers down there saying let's get
congressman smith so we're going to make
it so every time you put smith in their
upcoming race baiting,
but google's response was,
look,
we don't do individualized search
results like we give people what we
think people want based on what they've
done in the past and what they've shown
interest in.
And so that's what's producing this,
hits the machine that's producing this
result and that let congress lou come
back with,
if you don't like the connections,
than just don't enable them to be made
by doing things like don't do things
like race baiting.
Yeah.
If you don't want negative search
results,
don't do negative,
which is a pretty.
But.
But I do think tHat there's a really
hard problem here.
When you say it's the machine is doing
it,
you know,
what's the future gonna be like when we
can just say it's not my problem,
it's the machine that,
this is just facebook though when,
when you're talking about,
or google rather when you're talking
about twitter,
twitter has a different issue and their
issue is there's accusations of shadow
banning that they have decided that
they're going to silent voices
or make that much more difficult to find
or eliminate them from certain people's
feeds,
you know,
and they're doing this,
this,
the allegation that they're doing this
based on their own personal preferences,
their,
their beliefs that they're progressive
ideology wants them to lean left and
somehow or another distribute that
information in a much more left leaning
way.
And I hear these and I don't not an
expert on what they're doing.
And I wouldn't be surprised if,
you know,
certain complaints come in about certain
feeds and they say we're going to take
these off and that's the allegation.
And they haven't denied that.
And,
you know,
quite frankly,
some of these feeds,
you know,
Alex Jones stuff,
um,
you know,
if you're,
the consequences of your news show is
that somebody takes a gun to a pizza
shop in chicago in Washington to try to
prove that hillary clinton is running a
sex slave operation in the basement.
There's something wrong with what's
going on their child second child sex
life,
right?
Um,
so I understand why they feel like
they're a responsible there.
And you know,
it was recognized in the very beginning.
These companies have said we're going to
try to create a certain kind of
environment like so facebook required.
You identify yourself so that under the
shadows of anonymity you wouldn't be
causing wreaking lots of havoc inside
the system.
But look,
I think the more fundamental problem
here.
So what I've said so far,
people like google and facebook might
like,
here's stuff they're going to hate.
The more fundamental problem here is
that we have no antitrust enforcement of
any of these companies against any of
these companies.
And we've allowed them to become so
incredibly powerful without any
justification under the law.
Isn't the issue though,
that this was never anticipated that
this is when they created twitter,
they didn't think of it?
It's going to be.
It's going to be some voice of
distribution of information that's
unprecedenteD worldwide,
but that's what it is.
Yeah.
No,
they didn't expect no doubt.
They didn't expect it to work exactly
the way it worked,
but the antitrust law has from the
beginning had standards that should have
said we need to step in and certain
places.
So for example,
in 2010,
facebook is facing a pretty powerful
competitive threat from instagram.
And uh,
the question is what they're gonna do
like it's cooler to be instagram.
It's kids are using it much with the
growth rate is much faster in an
ordinary competitive market.
What they would do is they would build a
better product to compete with
instagram.
Their response was to write a check for
a billion dollars and they bought
instagram and um,
and they've bought a whole bunch of.
Other companies clearly have whatsapp,
which you know,
was a very important competitor in.
People believe they're really secure way
to communicate to them.
They by boston dynamics to have that.
That's amazing.
There's a.
There's a wikipedia page that has like
endless list of companies that they've
bought.
They're buying robots.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Funnel if that's true,
but the point is antitrust law in any of
these moments should have in
historically would have stepped in and
said,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
You can't buy your way into complete
dominance of these markets.
And I think one of the biggest changes
that's happened in the last 20 years is
at the antitrust department has Just
shot up its doors and just stopped doing
its work.
So if we had a more Competitive internet
environment where companies had to
compete against each other,
you'd have companies that try to compete
by protecting your privacy differently,
by refusing to sell your information
differently.
You'd have lots of pressure on companies
like facebook to behave,
not because idiot senators who don't
know how facebook works or calling them
before hearings,
but because the market itself is
creating the competition that drives
them to behave in a way that actually
conforms with what consumers want.
So I agree with you.
These are real questions and important
questions to figure out are they biasing
in one way or the other and if they're
biasing systematically,
that's a really important problem,
but the solution to that problem might
not be more government regulation.
The solution to that problem might be
governments making sure we have the
right kind of competition going on here
so that they can't get away with
behaving
well.
What would be that right?
Comic effect.
Google bought it and they actually sold
it last year.
Oh yeah.
Interesting.
Probably sold to the russians,
the Japanese,
japanese.
These like what would be the right kind
of competition?
It would have to be something that
balances it out,
right?
Like some sort of a right wing social
media platform,
but those tend to get infested with
trolls and four chan type people.
Then as soon as you say,
we're not gonna,
have any regulation.
I Mean the idea would be right.
you say,
oh,
google and facebook,
they are so progressive.
They lean left,
they suppress conservative voices and
they don't believe in freedom of speech,
so we're going to create a right wing
platform that allows freedom of speech
and doesn't suppress conservative voices
and you know what happens to those
things?
They get infested by four chan people
and the pepe the frog people and they
start saying racist things.
If I could say anything,
I'll say anything,
anything means anything,
and that's a real problem in today's day
and age because there's a lot of bored
people out there and they get excited
about a platform where they can say
something that they know is completely
outrageous under an anonymous screen
name and people think,
well,
this is indicative of a person's actual
real beliefs.
Sometimes.
Sometimes it's board people that are
trying to fuck with people and they're
trying to get a rise out of folks and
they know that if they write a bunch of
words and heil hitler,
that it's going to get a reaction and
then they'll check it every couple of
minutes to see what kind of,
ah,
look at all these people getting mad.
Ha ha.
This is what happens.
So incredibly progressive tea tends to,
when you think of someone as being
progressive or be having a progressive
voice,
you tend to think of being inclusive,
you know,
not supporting homophobia,
being open to all sorts of different
marginalized groups rights.
But when you think of conservative,
you open the door for a lot of people
that are rejected by these progressive
groups and they Might not necessarily be
conservative,
but they are not welcome in these
progressive spaces.
So they come out to these new places and
they,
it turns into a dumpster fire.
Yeah.
Look,
the stoRy you just described is the
story of cable television.
Cable television is that at a certain
point people like robert roger ailes and
murdoch's decided that we didn't have
enough conservative media out there.
And so they funded not just magazines
like the new republic,
but they funded the beginning of cable
television and um,
and that created this bifurcation in
media with cable television and one
could make these observations about,
I mean,
this is what you'll have done.
Clare's book is all about like what the
nature of truth is on cable television
on the right is different from what it
is on the left.
So I think that's all fair and I don't
think anybody has a clear sense of what
the right answer looks like in this
space.
I mean,
the reality is,
you know,
facebook is a technology.
I'm here,
facebook friends are going to really
hate me for this,
but here facebook is a technology to
exploit insecurity for the purpose of
selling ads.
That's what it does.
What it does is make you feel like
you've checked and you're like,
why didn't she like that photograph or
why isn't he friended me?
And so you constantly engage because
you're constantly trying to feed this
feedback and that is exploiting tristan,
tristan harris.
HiS work Is really a powerful here is
exploiting your insecurity.
Is that really what it is?
Because I've always thought about it as
being a fast food version of the
nutrients that we're missing in an
actual real community.
That's so good.
That's exactly the right way to think
about it,
but just in the same way that fast food
companies figure out how to exploit the
brain chemistry that makes it so that
you eat chicken wings,
you know,
barbecue chicken wings because they know
that's what's going to feed that kind of
addiction and just like gaming
companies,
figure out how to tweak the game so that
they'd know how to get the addiction out
of your kids.
This company is really great at getting
you to like turnover as much as you can
to them to builD you into this quote
community.
Why are they doing that?
Not because mark zuckerberg has come,
some kind of freaky guy who wants to
know your secrets,
but because the more you turn over to
them,
the better their ads are in feeding you
information.
So this is a technology for the purpose
of engendering advertising and so that
advertising gets really,
really good.
And so,
you know,
you could say that facebook is tilted to
the left,
but the reality is there is an
extraordinary amount of exploitation of
the advertising inside of facebook to
feed information to the right.
In this last election,
I mean as much,
I'm Kathleen Hall,
jayman says book about this.
It's really quite amazing and
documenting and that's because it's
gotten really good at being able to
segment markets on the basis of what
people know or care about.
Again,
not because anybody planned it,
nobody wrote jew hater,
but because the ai is smart enough to
figure that out,
and so when you build this technology
that is driven to the purpose of making
it easier to sell ads,
you produced this world that has no
necessary connection to figure people
figuring out what the truth is.
Again,
think of cable television.
Cable television is about building
really loyal community,
building the tribal sense of the
community.
If telling the truth did that,
they would tell the truth.
If not telling the truth does that they
will not tell the truth.
The question is not whether you're
telling the truth or not.
The question is what builds the
advertising base.
And so this,
this reality that we have these
platforms that are ad driven,
um,
distort or constructs drives that
platform to develop in certain ways.
And that's why I think it's important to
think,
well,
what if we could create a competitive
environment where there were different
platforms available once that we're not
focused on driving ads and this is
something that again,
I think they fund those.
Isn't that the reason why something like
google or facebook has gotten so big is
because of so much money behind it?
Well two things because they've been
allowed to get so big and because so
much money behind it stopped them.
The antitrust departments,
people,
antitrust department would step in and
say,
facebook,
you become too successful.
The way you're buying up competitors is
disturbing to us.
Well,
but again,
the thing of the difference in that
sentence,
you've become so successful.
That's one sentence.
And what we want to do in America is
encouraged companies to become
successful.
I believe in,
you know,
innovators and markets working that's
really great,
but you've bought your competitor is a
separate statement,
like you have a bunch of money because
the stock is so valuable because people
think you're the future of money,
but then you turn and use that money to
buy a competitor's.
What do you put in up jamie?
What is this?
That's the total number of they've spent
in the last,
I don't know,
I think it was seven years.
Saw the company as they bought.
Scroll back,
don't,
don't move.
Total cost of acquisitions.
What does that $23,000,000,000,000.
Billion,
billion.
Twenty $3,000,000,000
more than the gross domestic product of
Fiji.
Zimbabwe and mild dbs combined.
19 billion of that was for that one.
What's app?
Really?
19 billion.
Yeah.
Anyway.
Yeah,
so,
but the point is when you're talking
about acquisitions,
you're not necessarily talking about
companies that are succeeding because
they're so good.
Right?
So you know,
when you say what are the alternatives
going to look like?
It's a really hard question,
but we have some of it in real space.
Like we understand
npr has a different set of incentives
from fox news.
We understand podcasts have a different
set of incentives from youtube videos,
right?
You do videos of a different kind of
constraint.
If you did a three hour youtube video,
you would not live in the same way that
you get to live in the context of
podcasts.
But we do do a three hour youtube video,
but it doesn't get the success that it
gets because it's a three hour youtube
video.
It's because people are committed to
your podcast.
I mean I know these guys like a carry it
around and like when you get to a place
where it sounds like it's going to be
interesting to see what's on the video,
then they flip up the video.
But.
But you know the average successful
youtube video,
if you do a political youtube video,
you're told you can't be more than two
and a half minutes.
Then you've lost people.
But the point is the environments.
I don't necessarily think that's
correct.
Jordan peterson is doing a lot of really
long youtube videos that are very
successful,
doesn't hurt as podcasts.
There's a hunger right now for unedited
thought and not edited in under an
uncensored in terms of language,
but in terms of no one influencing what
you're saying.
So if you decided to do a podcast or a
thing on youtube and no one was leaning
over your shoulder with an agenda or a
guideline to follow,
there's a real hunger for that because
people feel like what you've described
about facebook and cable news,
that they're essentially just trying to
sell you things,
keep you on the hook so they can profit
from you.
There's a real hunger for someone who's
not doing that.
Right.
I agree.
This is why I feel like there's got to
be a market for news in that regard.
Like an actual unbiased,
uncensored,
raw,
truly objective centrist news station.
Well,
again,
I think that's the slow democracy
movement that podcast feeds because the
reality is if you had a simple way to be
watching in every second of your two
hour,
three hour podcasts,
what was working and what was not,
it'd be really hard for you to resist.
I would resist.
Okay.
I wouldn't pay attention to the thing
for a second car to you.
I've already been faced with that
before.
People have said to me,
oh,
well this is when people start tuning.
Throw that away.
Yeah,
but you know,
I know friends,
chris hayes will tell you about life on
msnbc where it.
see,
that's because of advertiser dollars.
Okay.
That's my point.
My point is the way to this is my whole
point about this platform,
this platform is in advertising driven
platform,
right?
That fact steers it in a certain way and
I saying we need to build alternative
platforms,
which was what you're building and the
in the pocket.
It's not like advertising is not
important to your stuff.
Of course you start with talking about
certain products that help sponsor what
you're doing.
So it's not anti market,
it's all for market.
But the point is it allows you to
develop the content in a way that's not
micromanaged by the advertising dollar
or the are the market incentive and
that's critically.
It's
also other people's incentive to get you
to do things in a way that they will
feel they feel will be more profitable
so that everybody gains.
Um,
I don't have those other people.
So there's no one else.
So if I,
but if I've done television shows
before,
when you do television shows before you
will have meetings with producers and
they will have notes and they will tell
you that this is hurting our bottom line
and this is not good for that or we have
to emphasize more of this or the network
wants that and it's really just about
accentuating your ability to make more
money.
Right?
Which is why we have to build these
alternatives that can compete with the
advertising driven platforms.
Well,
if you could get a really entertaining
news show on youtube or I mean,
I guess the young turks sorta tried
doing that,
but they leaned so hard left a bit,
but they attract an extraordinary number
of people and that's good.
But again,
you know,
we have this image of like new shows
have a version of walter cronkite.
Maybe that's not what it is.
Maybe you know,
the cupbearer report is a new show or
something.
Who's someone is mocking it as they're
delivering you the input that they're
giving you the information.
Someone who's objective.
I would like someone who's really
objective,
who talks about the negative
applications of whatever law or bill
it's being discussed.
Like what would be bad for everyone,
what would be good for democrats,
republicans,
poor people,
rich people.
You don't get that.
There's no version of that available
right now.
every version leans towards whatever
platform they're on,
whether it's fox news or msnbc.
Yeah.
I think not for want of trying.
I just think the world doesn't support
it,
but the world doesn't support it because
there's people are so tribal because
they want to be either on the fox news
camp or they want to be in the msnbc
camp.
I really feel like there's a lot of
people that just aren't being
represented and folks like me who just.
I want to know what,
what is happening?
Why?
Why is this the Case?
Why is this leaning in this direction?
What's the real motivation behind this
bill?
What's the real motivation behind these
actions?
Yeah,
and,
and the question is whether you're going
to get it from a single person who
purports to be quote objective or
whether you're going to get it from
three or four people like reading across
these different perspectives.
When I was a kid,
I was obsessed with the soviet union and
in 1982 I went to the soviet union.
I was like,
I guess I was 20,
just turned 21 and,
and I was hitchhiking through eastern
europe.
And then I went through the soviet union
and I was on a train from leningrad to
moscow and a sitting next to a
professor.
I always seem to be followed by people
who spoke english.
But this guy spoke english and he said
to me,
um,
you know,
we have a better system of free speech
and soviet union than you do in America.
How dare he,
eh?
So I said,
whaT the hell could that possibly mean?
And he said,
well,
when you wake up in the mornings,
he said,
uh,
when you wake up in the morning,
you read the New York times or the
Washington post or the wall street
journal and you think,
you know,
the truth,
but we know when we read our newspapers,
everybody's lying to us.
So we have to read seven or eight
newspapers and triangulate on the truth.
And that makes us a more critical free
speech society that America is.
And you know,
it's kind of funny at the time because
like,
you realize they didn't have any.
But there's a kernel of truth to that.
You know,
when my dad gets an email that says
barack obama's a muslim,
he comes from the time when you just
believe what's printed even though it's
not printed,
it's just an email.
And so he just kind of like,
oh my god,
the president of muslim.
Um,
but you know,
my kid gets an email that says barack
obama is a muslim.
He's like,
yeah,
well,
I mean,
what else mean?
Like he's going to be like,
yo,
you want to see different views.
And so I think that in some sense we are
producing a culture,
especially among our kids,
uh,
or at least one hopes where they
recognize that everything is partial.
Yes.
And you gotta you gotta do a lot of work
to Poland to knit it together.
And in the end that might be a better.
I might be a better ecology for
producing democracy and truth than one
where,
you know,
you've got to trust the source to be
objective in this case.
That's an interesting perspective.
Um,
I do definitely agree that young people
are more skeptical and more aware of the
possibilities of fuckery today than ever
before.
Here's a funny story.
Michael sherman,
you know,
michael shermer,
who is a professional skeptic.
Yeah.
I get a dm from him,
says,
uh,
there's a story about you on bc.
Uh,
uh,
what,
what is the british bbc is a story about
you on bbc.
You have to log into your twitter to
read it.
So I look at that.
I go,
what kind of bullshit?
This,
What'd you get hacked?
so I sent him a message,
say,
hey dude,
you get hacked.
They send him the message and he said,
what?
There's a story about me and he logged
in.
Shit,
he's a fucking professional skeptic.
Wow.
They got him.
But why?
Because he's older now.
You know?
I mean,
I think guys that didn't grow up with
that,
they don't or they don't know
tricksters.
They don't know the,
the,
the ways of it.
And it was a nightmare for him.
He'll like,
I mean his whole system was screwed up
and he had a j.
Every time it would make,
make a tweet,
it would get deleted.
Like it was really bad and I will email
them and go,
dude,
you got hacked.
yeah.
No,
it's a problem with us old people.
This is the way we live.
Well,
it's just you grow up with one system
and then all of a sudden you know,
I don't know what to do here.
Oh,
it says it needs my login.
Let me just give me a hug and that all
these pop up boxes.
And oh no.
The number of people who are being
tricked into believing the irs is
calling them on the telephone and
demanding.
Hilarious.
And tragic,
I mean this is amazing,
man.
Told me they're going to put my whole
family in jail.
My whole family.
They left a message.
Since you did not return our call,
we will put your whole family in jail.
My dad,
my whole family,
the dog to everybody.
What about the cats?
It's like,
what the fuck man.
Like they're trying to freak people out.
And it's an automated voice message
folks.
Yeah.
Old folks get roped into that stuff real
hard.
It's very sad.
It's very sad because a lot of them are
lonely and they don't have a lot of
companionship.
And they get these messages and they
don't know who to turn to to explain it
to
god.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
And you know,
so is there a reason to be hopeful here?
Well,
younger kids.
And uh,
the other thing that makes me really
hopeful is places like reddit,
you know,
so which forms are you going?
I know there's some really bad stuff.
Some of them are
great though,
but many of them are great.
But the point is what the greatness can
inheres in there demonstrating
incredible talents out there in the
world that,
you know,
in the 19 seventies just would have been
invisible.
Like you kind of looked at the world in
the 19 seventies,
which I remember the 19 seventies you
kind of thought they were great people
at the top,
you know,
they were all in television and,
and everybody else was kind of a troll.
But what red hat does every day,
you know,
I,
I'm obsessed with certain of these feats
adjuster.
Amazing.
But,
um,
it's like you read them like,
here's just some joe schmo out there
that's taken a bunch of data and data is
beautiful.
I'm like,
demonstrated something amazing by the
way he's built it.
And yoU get the sense that the world is
filled with these incredibly talented,
smart people everywhere who are,
you know,
many of them just have too much time.
But the point is they're out there
everywhere.
So if you ask why should we be hopeful?
It's that we develop these critical
attitudes.
We have this ability to think across.
And the army is filled with so many
incredibly talented people and the
internet surfaces it.
It makes it possible for us to at least
reach them.
Yes.
And then the question is can we use this
power leverage is power and actually do
something with the forces of evil that
now control.
I had an interesting moment last night
at the ice house comedy club where there
was a drunk couple in the front row that
we're talking really loud and they were
annoying all the people around them and
they were kind of chime in and heckling
and raising their hands and eventually
they got kicked out and it was pretty
fun.
Everybody was having a good time.
It was pretty,
pretty crazy.
Even as they were getting kicked out,
the rest of the audience was having a
good time because we're making fun of
it.
And I said,
as these people were getting kicked out,
I said,
this is basically us.
Most of us are cool.
There's a hundred and 50 people in here
and out of 150 people,
hundred 48 of them are having a great
time.
Everyone's drinking.
and and where all these comedians and no
one wants any extraordinary attention,
no one wants any special attention,
but to people fucked it up.
Now if you were next to those people,
you would say,
oh,
the crowd there sucks.
The people are always yelling things out
and they're drunks and they hackle will
because that those two people required
an exorbitant amount of attention that
they asked for more attention than
anyone else.
And if you use that bias sample group
and say,
well this is the crowd.
The crowd is these drunk people that
yelled at,
you know,
the fast majority of the crowd are
really polite fund people out having a
good time.
And they approached it with the perfect
attitude.
I think this is the world.
This is the world.
I think the world is.
There's a small percentage of people
that fuck things up for everybody.
And I think that this,
this is in terms of politics,
in terms of business,
in terms of everything,
is that.
Yes,
in terms of the net for sure.
And I think the net is the perfect
example of that.
If you're a person that gets.
If something happens to you and people
started attacking you online for it,
if you just noticed the number of people
thAt say you're involved in some sort of
a story,
right?
Say maybe there's a million people that
know about this story and you get a 150
people send you mean things.
You think at the end of the world,
150 people a unit.
You don't notice that it's a hunt.
You just see All these messages and it's
an.
It's unmanageable.
You like,
oh my god,
everyone hates me.
No,
a hundred and 50 people have decided to
take action and make you feel bad
because they feel bad.
It's a small number in terms of the
overall number of human beings,
but if you are louis,
c,
k and it's coming at you,
you're like,
holy shit.
The world fucking hates me.
you know,
and it's,
it's.
This is.
This is the situation that we're in
right now.
We just have so many voices.
It's incredible though because out of
all those voices,
as long as you're not personally trying
to figure it out and filter it yourself
with your own,
which is completely impossible,
but if you could just look at it
objectives from afar,
this is going to work itself out in a
far better way than has ever happened
before in our past.
There's never been this many voices and
our pastor has been like you were
talking about a select few voices that
walter cronkite's,
the whoever it is at the top and then
everyone else sort of had to wait for
the narrative to be spelled out for
them.
RighT.
That's not the case anymore.
That's right.
And,
and again,
I think it's the best of times and the
worst of times.
So it's the best of times because all
these new voices are bringing all sorts
of great perspective and insight and
intelligence to the story that wasn't
there before.
And that's great.
The problem is is if the infrastructure
that used to be there to kind of bring
us up,
bring us all up to kind of basic level
so that we understood the facts
disappears so they don't have anything
that kind of makes it so that we all
understand what's at issue and what's at
stake
and what the facts are so that we can
act as a democracy in a sensible way.
Then the question is how do we run a
democracy?
You know,
because if we could have all these
different,
you know,
I like to think about the difference
between the culture channel and the
democracy channels and the culture
channel.
This is the best of times by orders of
magnitude and the stuff on television
today is a billion times better than
anything from the 19 seventies in 19
eighties and it's.
That's a product of this incredible
competition and the fact that you can
have anything and any niche market and
as long as it's enough,
it makes sense to do it and that's
what's great.
But when you turn to the democracy
channel,
the same fragmentation,
the same niche market.
The same reality of us all living in
these different universes means we can't
address problems as a democracy with
even the same facts.
And that's a real problem because if we
all live in our own fact universe,
uh,
but we have to save face the same real
problems in the same real earth,
then we're not going to decide them in
any sensible way.
And How you solve that problem is really
hard.
Like we're not going back.
Thank god we're not going back to the 19
sixties.
It's just not going to be the case that
there are three channels we get to
watch.
That's just not going to happen.
And it's a great thing because we've got
all this amazing culture,
but what do we do on the democracy side?
How do we build a democracy?
Recognizing that everybody's not going
to spend all their time geeking out
about campaign finance,
reform legislation.
And,
and that's why I think we need to think
about these other ways to bring people
to some sense of understanding.
And you know,
brian calendar and a hunter mats were
the first people that brought me into
this.
Like they put me on their podcast and I
remember like not even knowing when he
did this,
like the length of that conversation and
thinking,
what are you going to cut this down to?
Like six minutes,
10 minutes.
HoW long did you guys talk?
I think we talked for an hour,
you know,
and then we're already done two hours
and 15 minutes.
Holy shit.
Yeah.
Was a time warp in this row.
Wow.
I can see that.
Yeah.
I mean,
but I remember thinking like in the
middle,
like I stopped and I thought whoa,
this is the,
this is the changing of the world,
this is it.
And as opposed to those panel shows,
those two talking heads for each other.
Like when you're on these cable
television shows and you've got 30
seconds to say something and,
and you know,
you linked it before and I think this is
really the key.
It's,
it's,
it's exactly like diet.
Like we recognize that we have been pUt
into a world right now where we all eat
shitty food because it's been designed
to make it so tasty.
Like we love it,
you know?
and the only way we reformed that,
if individuals,
one by one,
began to decide to eat the right stuff,
right?
You've got to Decide to,
to engage in the right kind of healthy
behavior to,
to be able to survive in this world
because the incentives of the market are
to sell you stuff that doesn't
necessarily do that.
It's the same thing with the information
space.
That's why the slow food movement is
like the slow democracy movement.
Like the slow food movement is how do
you produce food that's actually healthy
in a way that feeds you.
It feeds your body in the right way.
I think the slo democracy movement,
how do you feed a democracy and the
elements to that have got to be context
where people are free to get deeper than
30 seconds and if we don't build more of
those we're gonna have.
We're going to have a really desperate
time for democracy.
We're going to have what we have,
which is the rise of authoritarians
around the world.
Do you foresee the possibility of
alternative social media outlets sort of
viewing all the issues that people do
have with google or facebook or twitter
or any of these,
what are perceived to be biased sources
of information and coming up with
something that has clear protections in
there?
Sort of like the founding fathers did
when they established our system of
government that,
listen,
we don't want that.
Let's,
let's organize that as we're starting to
make sure that this doesn't doesn't ever
turn into some sort of an echo chamber.
Look,
I am way above my pay grade.
Yeah,
but what I know gets us there is
competition.
I know that the only thing that has ever
gotten us to the next great innovation
is the enforcement of competition,
which is why it's a problem when someone
like facebook absolutely buys in store.
What gave us the internet was
interventions by the government against
a t and t,
which was the dominant
telecommunications company for more than
a century that finally said,
enough of this,
you can't leverage your power to control
all innovation,
and once that intervention happened,
people could layer on top of their
wires,
a new network called the internet,
and when they did that,
government said to companies like cable
television companies,
okay,
yeah,
you've got broadband across your cable
line,
but that doesn't mean you get to decide
what applications go on that cable line.
So you,
you're hbs.
You mean near The cable company?
You can't say that there can't be
netflix on the cable or you can't slow
netflix down.
Now obviously they would want a slow
night fix down because netflix is a
competitor with their basic business
model,
but the intervention to assure
competition created the opportunity for
these great new innovations.
Now nobody at the beginning of that had
any clue about what would come out of
it.
All that they knew was that the only way
to get something new and create was to
assure competition.
And that's the commitment we've given up
since 2000,
since George Bush became president in
2001,
there's been no major enforcement action
by the antitrust department against any
of these companies.
And that is a huge problem.
And until we rediscover the importance
of competition,
not because we're geniuses and we can
figure out what the future will bring,
but because we know from the past that
the only way the future comes is if you
guarantee competition,
unless we do that,
we're never going to solve any of these
problems.
Yeah.
Ensuring competition is ensuring
innovations,
ensuring and anybody who doesn't want
competition wants to stifle innovation.
And it's got to be thought to be a
selfish proposition.
And the basic.
So you know,
the basic argument and competition law,
you know,
there's competition law got taken over
by a bunch of chicago economists who
said the only question was efficiency or
consumer welfare,
but there's another perspective that
libertarians like.
Luigi zingAles,
who's an economist,
that university of chicago business
school.
And um,
and people who are not libertarians like
tim wu who's a professor at columbia
embrace,
and this is the idea of political
antitrust and the idea of political
antitrust is you should also worry if
companies are so big that they can
corrupt the government,
like this is a dimension to worry about
too,
because if they get to be so big that
they can corrupt the government,
then you know that they will use that
power to protect themselves against
innovation.
Because if an innovator comes,
he doesn't come with 50 lobbyists.
He does comes with a great idea.
I mean,
you know,
elon musk saw this dramatically as he's
developing this incredible alternative
and tried to figure out how to sell it
inside of states.
And then the lobbyists for the car
companies would go state by state and
forbid them from being able to sell cars
without a local dealership in the state.
Right?
There was a huge fight as the incumbent
industries leveraged their power over
government to protect themselves from
this new competitor.
And this is the,
this is the fight we have to.
We have to make central again because if
we don't do that,
then the dinosaurs will have the power
through this corrupted political system
to protect themselves against the future
and this is just the moment when we need
to figure out how to make the future
come.
I'm glad you're raising these warning
flags,
but I feel like from talking to you that
you're fairly optimistic.
You're the first person who's ever said
that.
Really feel like you're optimistic.
You're perception of the internet and
the young people coming up and the.
Okay.
That's fair.
The way information is being distributed
today,
that there's so many people
participating in it and there's so much
competition even in that form.
Right?
I mean there's.
Yeah,
there's more voices now and there's a
lot of.
Look in the past when you had to be
selected in order to speak,
it was very difficult to get through
that selection process and it's not
necessarily the best voices that got
through it.
Just sometimes the most persistent and
the most influential,
whatever the reason why they got it to
be one of those people with the tie in
that block on those panel shows,
that's not the case anymore.
Right.
You know,
now you've got kyle kalinsky,
you've got all these,
you know these,
these people that are.
They don't necessarily fit in,
you know,
any traditional jimmy dore,
they don't fit in any traditional role
on regular mainstream television,
but they have a pretty influential
voice.
Absolutely.
And they're very polItically savvy and
they're talking about things in a way
that they would be.
they would be.
it would be very hard to get a producer
to sign off on the way a lot of these
guys communicate and some of the things
that they do be.
It would be very,
very difficult,
but.
So you're optimistic.
I'm very optimistic.
I'm optimistic in that space.
I guess everything outside of the
beltway of Washington,
I'm optimistic about.
I think America has an incredible
capacity to innovate out of its
problems.
What I fear and what I'm not sure any
rational person should be optimistic
about,
but that doesn't mean you don't fight
it.
What I fear is Washington and um,
and so I've said many times like the
power of corruption in Washington might
be so great that it cannot be defeated,
but that doesn't affect what we should
be doing.
We should be fighting it.
Whether or not we think we can win.
Winning is not the only reason you
fight.
You fight because it's the right thing
to do and we need to rally because we
might be wrong.
It could just be that if we got the
political forest,
we could take them down and,
and I think that's what we got to be
setting up for it right now.
When you see people like tulsi gabbard
or will you see this young woman in New
York,
alexandria,
a casio,
casio cortez,
that to me that's very promising,
that people are leanIng in this
direction and that they're,
they're saying,
let's just,
let's,
let's look at this in a different way
and let's see some new voices.
Let's,
let's hear people that are clearly not
influenced by corporate America.
They're clearly not.
They don't have all of their veins
hooked up to the matrix yet.
Now I tulsa I had known before your
interview with her,
your interview with her I think gave
people a incredible understanding of the
depth of her soul,
which is deep.
How about when she tweeted to the
president,
making us Saudi Arabia is bitch is not
putting us America first so she can go.
She can both do the deep and also the
shallow.
She can do both.
That's amazing.
That is an unprecedented thing too
because what trump has done is he's
opened up the door for this kind of very
hostile communication,
but what he's also done is opened up the
door for it to come back at him.
Not that he notices,
but the.
You're right,
exactly right.
The rest of the world notice,
but what I think is interesting about
alexandria is she is very disciplined
about saying,
look,
we've got to fix the system if we're
going to get any of these things done.
So I like to think about like alexandria
or versus bernie,
you know,
so she like every time she gets up there
and talks about her green energy,
new deal,
it's like you got to fix the political
system and then we're going to be able
to get this stuff as opposed to like
putting a list of 10 things you want to
do without anywhere even mentioning the
fact that you're going to make these
things possible by pixeling fixing
political system.
I think we need new people,
which this new congress is filled with
them.
There were a hundred and seven members,
a lot of people running for congress who
wrote to speaker of the house and said
they want.
As the first thing is addressing of this
corrupt political system.
And nancy pelosi gave them,
not just that,
but all these other reforms to it.
That's hr one.
The younger people coming into congress,
realIzed the system is broken.
I fear the older people in congress have
gotten so used to the system that they
don't even notice anymore.
Just how broken it is,
how outrageous it is,
and they need to rage.
So they're going to rage against the
billionaires or whatever,
but I think we need to focus the rage on
the problem and that problem is
congress.
If we don't fix congress first,
nothing else matters.
Nothing else will happen and we need to
build the movement,
which I think could actually be a
movement that brings people on the right
and people on the left in to make that
change possible.
The philosophy that you have to have
darKness in order to inspire light and
that there's some sort of a balance to
be achieved in this managing of those
two energies And that when you have an
administration that's clearly fucked up
and then people come along and say,
it's time that I get into politics and
make a difference and these are the
people that are motivated because they
see a need for change.
Whereas some people with other
administration,
so like I liked the way things are
going.
I'm going to go pursue the private
sector.
I'm going to go do this.
I'm going to do people see something
like what's happening with trump?
And they say,
I want to.
I want to stop this.
This is not the America that I know.
There are people entering politics for
the best possible and I think people in
the right have entered politics for the
best possible reason and people in the
left to the question is how quickly do
they get bent by the system?
How quickly do they become part of the
system,
the dark side of the forest?
Because like when you like,
you know,
when you say members of congress spend
30 to 80 percent of them,
70 percent of the time raising money,
you might think that means they're
miserable most of the time,
but you know,
there's a way in which it's actually
psychologically rewarding for them.
So,
um,
you know,
to be a member of congress right now is
a pretty miserable job.
You don't get much done.
Like you're spending all your time like
rats in a maze.
Like the bell goes off.
You've got to run to the floor.
Your aide tells you how your two votes,
you vote and you leave from the floor.
It's nothing like what the framers
imagined.
Like they were sitting on the floor
listening to debate about ideas.
All that's bullshit.
The only debate is debate to cspan as
like a speech to cspan and,
and that's,
and that's what it is.
So the life of a congressman is pretty
miserable,
but um,
but when they fundraise,
it's kind of like pushups,
you know,
sit down and they're told,
okay,
you've got to raise $20,000.
And uh,
the aid sit there and say call joe,
he cares about this and call fred and he
cares about that.
And you go through and when you hit your
numbers,
it's like,
hooray,
I did something.
So it's like,
you feel like you're accomplishing
something,
but the point is the psychology of that
increasingly makes you okay with the
system that you're in and you realize
you win in that system.
You've won under that system.
And so your openness to changing the
system becomes
really sketchy.
So I think the critical moment right now
is to,
is to solidify the recognition this
congress is corrupted and we have to fix
it.
and you know,
the only thing I'm worried about with hr
one is that it's gonna make it into a
democratic issue.
It's like that democrats care about it,
so the republicans are supposed to not
care about it.
The critical thing now is to get
republicans to support the idea of
reform and then make it something other
than just a traditional tribal fight
between left and right.
Are you optimistiC?
Was I correct in that I'm optimistic
about everything outside of the beltway
and I'm going to fight like hell to,
to,
to prove that we can fix stuff inside
the beltway.
But if you told me I had to bet on my
son or daughter's life,
I'm not going to tell you that.
I think we're going to say I would never
ask you to do.
Okay,
good.
All right.
We're clear.
Thank you for doing this.
I really appreciate it.
I really enjoyed talking to you.
Let's do this again.
Hopefully you'll be right every time you
ask.
All right,
we'll do it.
Thank you sir.
Appreciate it.